Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast von ESA und DLR. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zur 32. Ausgabe dieser Gesprächsserie, wo es um die Raumfahrt geht und viele Aspekte, die die Raumfahrt so umgeben. Und vor zwei Sendungen haben wir hier ein Gespräch geführt mit Michael Kahn von der ESA über das Projekt Cassini-Huygens, der Sonde beziehungsweise dem Sondenpaar, was sich auf den weiten Weg gemacht hat zum Saturnsystem. Dort die Sonde Huygens abgesetzt hat auf dem Mond, Titanen und viele Erkenntnisse, die aus dieser Mission heraus entstanden sind. Und diese Sendung heute ist in gewisser Hinsicht eine Ergänzung, Erweiterung und Anschluss an diese Folge. Denn heute soll es um das Saturnsystem als solches gehen, also mehr der Blick auf die wissenschaftliche Seite, den Kenntnisstand über dieses System. Und dazu bin ich heute in Berlin beim DLR, beim Institut für Planetenforschung, wo ich auch schon zweimal war, wo es hier schon ein interessantes Gespräch über Planetenforschung als solches gab und auch über die Kometen im Besonderen. Heute also ganz speziell auf das Saturnsystem. Und anders als sonst habe ich heute auch gleich mal zwei Gäste zu begrüßen. Und zwar Ralf, Ralf Jaumann. Ja, ihr seid beide hier aus derselben Abteilung. Abteilung Planeten und Geologie, eben hier an dem schon erwähnten Institut für Planetenforschung vom DLR. Planeten und Geologie klingt ja sehr allgemein. Worum kümmern sich denn die anderen Abteilungen? Wie ist denn das abgegrenzt?
Also erst mal, wir sind nicht aus derselben Abteilung. London, wir ergänzen uns hier perfekt. Frank Solis aus der Abteilung Planetenphysik. Und die Geologie beschäftigt sich in erster Linie mit dem, was man direkt sehen kann, mit den Oberflächen von Planeten und Monden. Und die Physik beschäftigt sich mit dem Inneren dieser Körper. Und beides zusammen gibt eigentlich ein ganz gutes Verständnis dessen, wo kommt das Zeug her, wie ist es entstanden, wie hat es sich entwickelt und was sind die letzten noch Geheimnisse bei der Geschichte. Und insofern haben wir auch so ein bisschen so ein Spiel von direkter Beobachtung, was die Geologie macht und theoretischer Modellierung, weil ins Innere kann man ja nicht reinschauen. Aber das muss natürlich hinterher zusammenpassen. Das heißt, die Modelle über die Planetenentstehung, die Mondentstehung, die man sich macht, die muss natürlich mit dem zusammenpassen, was man als letzte Spuren auf der Oberfläche noch sehen kann.
Das heißt, bei der Geologie hat man es eigentlich erst mal besser?
Na ja, man hat es insofern besser, weil man wirklich was direkt greifen kann. Aber man sieht natürlich immer nur den letzten Prozess. Man sieht nicht das letzte Ergebnis des Prozesses. Man sieht aber nicht, was abgelaufen ist. Und wir wollen ja natürlich in der Zeit zurückschauen. Wir wollen ja sehen, wie hat das alles angefangen. Und dazu muss man natürlich dann Modelle entwickeln. Und die muss man immer wieder mit dem vergleichen, was man in der Wirklichkeit findet. Und zum Schluss wird dann die richtige Geschichte draus.
Wie stellt sich das aus deiner Perspektive dar?
Also die Planetenphysik nutzt zusätzlich zu dem, was sozusagen an der Oberfläche auch sichtbar ist, noch viele Informationen, die aus dem Studium der Magnetfelder beispielsweise kommen, sofern sie vorhanden sind, der schwere Felder, der Gravitationsfelder, des Rotationszustandes eines Planeten oder Satelliten. Und genauso interessant ist es, zum Beispiel zeitabhängige Phänomene zu betrachten, wie zum Beispiel die Zeiten, die auch eine Rolle spielen, werden im Saturn-System. Und zusammen, wenn man diese Informationen zusammennimmt, kann man auf die Art und Weise auch wesentlich besser eben Modelle einschränken. Modelle des Inneren, auch Modelle der inneren Dynamik, die dazu führen oder die dadurch getrieben werden, dass Wärme, die im Inneren entsteht, nach außen transportiert werden muss. Das sind verschiedene Mechanismen, die da eine Rolle spielen und die wir im Rahmen unserer Abteilungsarbeit untersuchen und die sowohl gültig sind für beispielsweise silikatische Körper wie die Erde, Maus, Venus und Mond, aber eben auch eine Rolle spielen im äußeren Sonnensystem, wo wesentliche Zusammensetzungen letztlich, wesentliche Bestandteile der Zusammensetzungen auch planetare Eise sind.
Hier wird ja eigentlich alles beforscht, also eine einzelne Abteilung widmet sich jetzt nicht nur einem einzelnen Planeten. Welche Rolle spielt jetzt konkret das Saturn-System bei der Arbeit bei euch?
Saturn-System und auch Jupiter-System sind natürlich für uns insofern wichtig, weil es sind so kleine Welten, man kann fast sagen kleine Sonnensysteme. Das ist ein großer Körper und sehr, sehr viele Monde. Und im Saturn-System ist das extrem ausgeprägt. Die meisten Monde sind im Saturn-System, die haben alle unterschiedliche Größen. Und das macht einmal dynamisch, kann man sehr schön untersuchen, was da passiert. Man kann aber auch sehr genau untersuchen, wie solche Dinge sich entwickeln, wie sie entstanden sind, wo diese Körper herkommen, wie sie sich gebildet haben. Und man hat sozusagen eine Welt im Kleinen. Und deswegen macht es die Sache interessant. Zusätzlich kommt natürlich, weil in jeder Stelle im Sonnensystem gibt es eigentlich das sehr, sehr große Vau. Jeder Körper hat so ein, oder jeder Planet hat so ein richtig großes Erlebnis. Und beim Saturn ist es natürlich der Mond Titan, der einzige Mond mit einer Atmosphäre unter besonderen Bedingungen. Das ist ein fantastisches Labor. Wir haben tiefe Temperaturen dort. Wir können beobachten, was andere flüchtige Elemente tun bei tiefen Temperaturen, wenn sie nicht mehr flüchtig sind. Also wir haben dort Methan. Und Methan verhält sich auf Titan, genauso wie sich das Wasser auf der Erde verhält.
Aber tiefe Temperaturen sind ja nicht gerade selten, oder?
Naja, umso weiter sie nach draußen gehen, umso weiter gehen die Temperaturen runter. Und es wird ja nicht alles bei den Temperaturen im Sonnensystem fest. Sie müssen schon verdammt weit raus, bis sie CO2 oder Methan flüssig und fest bekommen. Und andere Gase, z.B. Ammoniak und so, müssen noch weiter raus. Das ist eine spannende Frage, was passiert da. In unserem Wissen über diese Dinge sind wir ja durchaus etwas eingeschränkt. Wir können nicht alles auf der Erde unbedingt nachvollziehen. Wir können zwar die tiefen Temperaturen herstellen, aber wir können z.B. keine tiefen Temperaturen und gleichzeitig Vakuum herstellen. Es gibt schon Bedingungen, die funktionieren nur im Weltraum und Temperaturbedingungen funktionieren nur, umso weiter man nach draußen geht. Bei Pluto sind sie dann irgendwo noch bei 40 Grad Kelvin. Da ist es dann ein gewaltiges Labor, um zu wissen, was bei tiefen Temperaturen noch möglich ist, was nicht möglich ist, was funktioniert, was geht. Das hat natürlich auch wieder Auswirkungen auf das Verständnis, das wir über Geologie haben. Was ich gerade schon erwähnt habe, Flüssigkeiten verhalten sich wie Flüssigkeiten. Wir haben beim Titan zum Beispiel gelernt, dass Methan das Gleiche tut, geologisch, wie Wasser auf der Erde. Es fließt über die Oberfläche, es macht Flusstähler, es erodiert die Oberfläche, es transportiert Material. Das ist etwas, was es vor der Cassini-Emission in diesem Selbstverständnis nicht gegeben hat. Wir wussten einfach nicht, dass andere Flüssigkeiten sich wirklich exakt so verhalten wie Wasser auf der Erde.
Die Cassini-Huygens-Mission war insofern dann auch Zeitenwende, ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie hoch ich das aufhängen soll, aber es war schon natürlich eine komplette Änderung der Wissensbasis. Was war der Blick auf das Saturn-System? Was wusste man, bevor diese Mission losgegangen ist? Was hat man geahnt und was war eine gesicherte Erkenntnis?
Wenn wir davon ausgehen, was wir vorher wussten, ist, umso weiter wir ins Sonnensystem rausgucken, umso eher müssen wir hinfliegen, um was rauszubekommen, denn von der Erde mit Teleskopen ist nicht mehr viel zu machen. Die Mission, die vorher ein Saturn-System war, das war Voyager und Voyager war ein Vorbeiflug. Das heißt, man ist durch das Saturn-System durchgeflogen. Das dauert zwei, drei Tage. Die hat man Zeit zu beobachten. Und das ist natürlich für so einen gewaltigen Komplex verdammt wenig. Also man hat ein bisschen was angerissen und ist natürlich dann mit sehr, sehr vielen Fragen stehen geblieben.
Was hat denn Voyager überhaupt erst an neuer Erkenntnis gebracht?
Voyager hat sehr viel an Erkenntnis gebracht, zum Beispiel über das Verhältnis, über bahndynamische Verhältnisse. Wir wussten zum Beispiel vorher nicht, wie diese Ringe funktionieren, warum manche dicke, manche dünner sind, dass da Monde mitfliegen, wo die Lücken herkommen, cassinische Teile, enkische Teilung im Ringsystem. Das sind alles Dinge, die man eigentlich mit Voyager rausbekommen hat, wie die Ringe überhaupt aufgebaut sind. Man hat durchaus gewusst, dass Titan eine Atmosphäre hat, aber man hat sich die Atmosphäre dann anfangs doch ziemlich anders vorgestellt. Zum Beispiel nicht so extrem dicht, wie sie dann letztlich ist. Voyager konnte da nicht sehr viel erledigen.
Aber man wusste schon, dass der Titan eine Atmosphäre hat.
Ja, das kann man von der Erde mit Teleskopen machen. Mit Spektroskopie feststellen, dass dort Gase sind. Okay, man hat da natürlich eine ganze Menge neue Monde gefunden durch Voyager. Also kleine Körper, relativ kleine Körper, die den Saturn umkreisen. Und man hat natürlich das erste Mal Einblick auf die Oberfläche dieser Monde bekommen. Man hat ein Magnetfeld gemessen. Man hat alles, was man so in den großen ersten Überblick über so ein System rausbekommen kann. Aber wie gesagt, ich muss mich vorstellen, sie fliegen dahin jahrelang und dann fliegen sie in, ich glaube, drei Tagen maximal. Durch das System durch und da haben sie alle ihre Messungen gemacht haben und das war es dann. Da können sie natürlich nur feststellen, dass sie eigentlich noch viel länger hätten dort bleiben wollen und noch viel mehr, viel genauer hätten sehen wollen. Insbesondere Titan ist ein Geheimnis geblieben. Deswegen hat man sich ja auch entschlossen, da braucht man gar nicht erst lang rumfliegen. Wenn wir da wirklich was rauskriegen wollen, dann müssen wir dort landen.
Das ist so ein bisschen, als würde man mit einem Düsenjet über einen neuen Schwanstein fliegen und danach alle Aspekte von Burgentechnologie herausfinden wollen. Inwiefern war denn das Interesse schon groß? Also ich meine, man wusste so einiges. Cassini-Huygens war ja schon eine extrem ambitionierte Mission. Allein schon durch diese Doppelmission, dass man sowohl sich des gesamten Saturn-Systems angenommen hat als auch speziell dann eben des Titans. Also das Interesse war schon sehr groß, vermute ich mal, in der ganzen wissenschaftlichen Gemeinde. Oder?
Ohne Frage. Wenn Sie allein schon die Beteiligungen angucken. Ich hab zwar die Zahl jetzt nicht im Kopf, aber es sind ein paar hundert Wissenschaftler, die da dran arbeiten. Und die Dimension von Cassini selber ist auch geweißt, das größte Raumschiff, das jemals gebaut wurde und geflogen ist. Abgesehen von Apollo. Also das größte unbemannte Raumschiff. Das sind natürlich alles Dinge, die, ja, und es ist, hat natürlich auch eine dementsprechende Menge Geld verschlungen oder verschlingt es noch. Aber die einzige Chance, weit draußen im Sonnensystem wirklich zu verstehen, was passiert ist. Und das hat natürlich die Erforschung im Detail hat natürlich auch wieder mit dem Großen Ganzen zu tun. Ich meine, wir haben ein Sonnensystem mit Planeten. Wir finden inzwischen auch sonst im Universum sehr viele Sonnensysteme mit Planeten. Und all die, die wir dort finden, haben relativ große Planeten, so eben wie unser Jupiter und Saturn. Gibt auch kleinere. Die richtige Erde hat man bei denen noch nicht gefunden. Aber wie hängt das zusammen? Und wie hängt Jupiter und Saturn mit unserem eigenen System zusammen? Es gibt sehr, sehr viele Theorien, die darüber sagen, die zwei haben sich so, weil sie ja auch relativ nah beieinander sind, haben sich glücklicherweise und zufälligerweise so aufgeschaukelt und ihre Bahnen hingefunden, dass im Inneren Platz geblieben ist, dass sich die Gesteinsplaneten bilden konnten. Das ist nicht in jedem Sonnensystem so. Heißt also, da sind viele, viele Zufälle, die damit spielen. Das heißt, es geht nicht nur einfach um dieses System, Saturn-System, sondern es geht immer bei den Fragestellungen eigentlich um das ganze Sonnensystem. Wie ist das Sonnensystem entstanden? Warum ist es so, wie es ist? Und dann letztlich auch wieder zurück zu der Frage, wie konnte in diesem System zum Beispiel eine Erde entstehen? Und wie konnte auf der Erde Leben entstehen? Und wo kommen wir eigentlich her? Also das hat schon alles damit zu tun.
Ich möchte gerne den Faden nochmal aufnehmen. An der Stelle ist es wirklich wichtig zu betonen, dass Jupiter und Saturn eben gut, oder mehr als 95% der Masse des gesamten Sonnensystems darstellen. Also des Planetensystems ohne die Sonne. Und dementsprechend ist es schon auch sehr wichtig, diese beiden, speziell diese beiden Gasriesen, auch sehr gut zu verstehen. Und ihre entsprechenden Satellitensysteme. Und Voyager hat, wie eben schon angesprochen, eine Art Vorerkundung unternommen, auch des Saturn-Systems. Hat die Dynamik der Saturnatmosphäre recht gut untersuchen können. Die Orientierung des Magnetfels des Saturn, das letztlich auch indirekte Einflüsse hat auf die Oberflächen der Mone beispielsweise. Und allein durch die Beobachtung, die die Voyager-Mission erbracht hat, wurden ganz viele neue wissenschaftliche Fragen gestellt, die einfach nur im Rahmen einer Mission beantwortet worden konnten, die eben im Orbit ist des Saturn-Systems. Und die den Titan, den massereichsten dieser Monde eben nutzt, um im Saturn-System entsprechend zu navigieren und sich die übrigen Monde aus allen möglichen Positionen genauer anzusehen.
Verstehe, das heißt der Titan war jetzt nicht nur Objekt der Begierde selbst, sondern auch noch ein nützliches Hilfsmittel, um überhaupt einen komplexen Durchflug zu organisieren?
Titan ist sozusagen der Schlüssel in der ganzen Geschichte. Wir fliegen bei jedem Orbit einmal an Titan vorbei, weil man die Gravitationskraft von Titan nutzt, um irgendwelche Bahnänderungen durchzuführen. Und damit spart man natürlich jede Menge an Energie. So viel Treibstoff können sie gar nicht mitnehmen, um das zu tun. Ist natürlich dann auch immer wieder gezwungen, den Titan anzufliegen. Das, was natürlich gut ist, das liefert kontinuierlich Daten über Titan. Die Beiflüge an den anderen Monden sind nicht so häufig. Insofern ist die Mission natürlich auch allein schon durch die Bedingungen im Saturn-System auf den Titan fixiert. Und dann braucht man den Titan auch, um größere Bahnänderungen durchzuführen. Das heißt, man will ja eigentlich aus der Ekliptik auch raus. Man will auch mal in den polaren Orbit gehen, um natürlich überall das Magnetfeld und die Wechselwirkung mit dem Plasma zu untersuchen. Sodass es ein äußerst komplexes Verfahren und ein Navigationssystem ist, das dort durchgeführt wird. Also ich denke, das ist schon eine ingenieurtechnische Meisterleistung, die da seit 2004 absolviert wird.
Also 2004 ist Cassini angekommen im Saturn-System. Die Meisterleistung begann schon deutlich früher, beim Anflug, aber Cassini funktioniert immer noch problemlos.
Ja, aber sie müssen natürlich riesige Mengen an Planungsarbeit da reinstecken. Sie sind weit weg. Das Raumschiff muss ziemlich viel selber tun, weil sie einfach so lange Kommunikationszeiten haben. Das ist inzwischen auch schon ziemlich alt. Also wir sind da nicht mehr auf dem neuesten Stand der Technik. Cassini gebaut wurde, da waren Computer noch... Computer in Raumschiffen sind heute immer noch relativ dumm. Sie müssen aber sehr, sehr viel aushalten. Also nicht vergleichbar mit dem, was wir heute auf dem Schreibtisch stehen haben. Und die von Cassini sind noch älter. Cassini fliegt in einem ziemlichen Magnetfeld unter ziemlich harten Strahlungsbedingungen. Alles muss funktionieren. Und man muss natürlich dafür sorgen, dass man die Navigation so hinbekommt und die Bahnen so hinbekommt, dass alle wissenschaftlichen Interessen befriedigt werden. Denn die Mission ist teuer. Man ist da draußen, man weiß, man ist nur einmal dort. Und ich bin sicher, dass wir zu unseren Lebzeiten nicht noch einmal hinfliegen. Zumindest nicht mit so einer großen Geschichte. Weil wir schon alles erledigen, wenn man dort ist.
Ja, blicken wir doch mal von oben und aus der Ferne auf das Saturn-System. Es ist ja schon angeklungen, es ist halt ein sehr komplexes Gebilde. Viele Monde, diese Ringe sind glaube ich auch nicht einmalig, aber auf jeden Fall dort auch am stärksten ausgeprägt. Was macht jetzt für den Wissenschaftler, wenn man jetzt sagt, okay Saturn-System, was gehört da jetzt alles dazu? Also natürlich der Saturn.
Man gliedet generell in diese drei Komponenten. Man hat den Saturn selber, das ist der Planet. Man hat das Ringsystem. Das ist sehr, sehr bedeutend beim Saturn. Anderen großen Körper haben auch Ringe, aber nicht so schön. Und wir haben natürlich eine ganz große Anzahl von Mond. Das ist das, was wir so sichtbar kliedern können. Das, was wir ein bisschen weniger sichtbar kliedern können, sind natürlich Effekte von Magnetfeld. Das natürlich auch wieder wechselwirkt mit den Monden. Das ganze System rotiert, auch das Magnetfeld rotiert. In diesem Magnetfeld bewegen sich Monde, die auch mit dem Magnetfeld wieder wechselwirken. Das ist ja grundsätzlich genommen, aber kann Frank Sol bedeuten mehr drüber sagen. Grundsätzlich genommen so was wie, wir befinden uns in einem Teilchemischleuniger an dieser Geschichte. Und die Monde haben natürlich auf ihrer Oberfläche ziemlich viele Spuren von den Entwicklungen oder von den Wechselwirkungen mit dem Magnetfeld.
Also wir müssen uns da drüber im Klaren sein, dass Saturn sehr rasch rotiert um seine eigene Achse.
Was heißt das, rasch? Zirka zehn Stunden, ein bisschen mehr als zehn Stunden, also doppelt so schnell als Erde.
Dementsprechend stark abgeplattet ist er auch, hat die größte Abplattung aller Gasmonde im Sonnensystem. Das wäre ein Kürbis. Das bedeutet, da das Magnetfeld auch mitrotiert, dass die Monde, die wesentlich langsamer den Saturn umkreisen, sozusagen einen Teilchenstrom bekommen, der sie von hinten her anströmt. Dementsprechend sind auch die Oberflächen starken Veränderungen unterworfen, durch die Teilchen, die letztlich...
Wo kommen jetzt diese Teilchen her?
Diese Teilchen werden teilweise von den Monden selbst in die Saturn-Magnetosphäre injiziert. Sie werden dort elektrisch aufgeladen, dementsprechend beschleunigt. Es gibt allerdings auch neutrale Teilchen in das Saturn-System, Staubteilchen, die einen großen Anteil an Teilchenpopulationen innerhalb der Umgebung des Saturn haben. Wenn diese Teilchen die Oberflächen treffen, dann sorgt das letztlich für Veränderungen in der Struktur des Eises an den Oberflächen, die sich dann auch wiederum im optischen Halt entsprechend niederschlagen.
Was heißt das im optischen Niederschlagen?
Das heißt, sie können ja das Eis verändern. Wir wissen es ja auf der Erde. Eis unter verschiedenen Temperaturen, gibt verschiedene Schneeflocken. Wenn sie jetzt hergehen und da mit so einem Teilchenstrom ununterbrochen draufhauen, das ist also wie ein Sandstrahlgebläse, so kann man sich das vorstellen, dann verändern sie natürlich die Oberfläche auf der Rückseite anders als auf der Vorderseite. Die ganzen Saturn-Monde rotieren gebunden, d.h. sie zeigen immer dieselbe Seite dem Saturn. Sie haben immer eine definierte Vorderseite und eine definierte Rückseite. Das Magnetfeld rotiert jetzt so schnell, dass es die Dinger immer von hinten anklatscht. Und zwar bedeutend schneller, als sie sich um den Saturn bewegen. Also kriegen sie diesen Teilchenstrahl immer hinten drauf. Wie gesagt, wie ein Sandstrahlgebläse. Das heißt, das Eis auf der Rückseite wird anders verändert, als auf der Vorderseite. Natürlich ist der Raum zwischen den Monden und dem Saturn selber nicht komplett frei. Wir haben dort neben den geladenen Teilchen in diesem Feld auch jede Menge Staub und Dreck, der natürlich auch mit relativ großen Geschwindigkeiten fliegt. Und wenn die zusammen treffen, dann machen die kleine Löcher auf der Oberfläche. Das kann auch auf der Vorderseite passieren. Wir nennen das Art Erosion, das heißt also eine Abtragung der Oberfläche durch diesen Sandstrahleffekt. Und dadurch treten Veränderungen auf, die ganz ehrlich sagen, noch nicht so 100% verstanden sind. Das heißt also, wir wissen jetzt nicht, was genau passiert mit einem Eiskristall, wenn ein bestimmtes Proton mit einer bestimmten Energie dieses Eiskristall trifft. Das führt zu einer Veränderung. Aber was genau passiert und wie genau diese Prozesse sind, das ist eine spannende Frage. Und die kann man sehr gut im Saturn-System untersuchen, ist aber nicht einfach zu lösen.
Das heißt, dieser klassische Blick mit so, naja, da sind da diese Planeten hinten im Weltall, da ist irgendwie alles ganz einsam und da passiert auch nicht viel und kalte Körper rotieren so umeinander herum. Davon kann man sich verabschieden. Das ist eigentlich eher wie so eine Autowaschstraße. Alle haben so einen Strahler in der Hand und hauen sich das gegenseitig um die Ohren. Und es ist ein permanenter Veränderungsprozess, der da stattfindet.
Richtig. Und der findet aber schon eben seit 4,5 Milliarden Jahren statt, seit das passiert ist. Und der ist sicherlich früher ein bisschen heftiger gewesen, als er heute ist. Aber es sind auch Veränderungen, die wirklich heute stattfinden. Und wir sehen das ja auch zum Beispiel bei dem Mond den Zelladus, der wieder aus dem Inneren Gase ausschleudert. Das heißt also, wir nennen das Kryovulkanismus, also Eisvulkanismus. Das ist so was Ähnliches wie ein Geiss hier. Und das geht natürlich sofort in den kalten Weltraum, 90 Grad Kelvin. Dort gefriert das sofort und wenn man durch diese Gaswolke durchführt, dann fliegt das eben nicht nur Eis, sondern man sieht eine ganze Menge von anderen Gasen, sieht auch organische Verbindungen, also Methan, Ethan und höhere. Das heißt also, das ist eine ganz verrückte Welt. Und diese Gaswolke, die bringt natürlich Material in die Umlaufbahn von Enceladus. Und das Eis, das da in der Umlaufbahn ist, das ist ein richtiger Mantel, das heißt, der Mond fliegt durch seinen eigenen Dreck. Und das regnet immer wieder auf ihn runter. Das heißt also, die Oberfläche ist dadurch relativ frisch und relativ hell, weil eben sehr, sehr viel von dem Eis, das da rauskommt, wieder auf seine Oberfläche fliegt. Aber gleichzeitig bildet sich ein Ring. Und die kleinen Partikel, die Eispartikel und andere Partikel aus dem Inneren, CO2 oder was es sonst noch gibt dort, das bewegt sich natürlich auch wieder in diesem System. Und das trifft es nach außen und nach innen und trifft auch die anderen Monde. Das ist natürlich die spannende Frage bei der Geschichte. Was tut so ein kleiner Mond? Ein Zellatos hat 500 Kilometer Durchmesser. Das ist jetzt nicht viel. Wie kann der das machen? Wie kann der innen so warm sein? Wo nimmt er die Energie her für seinen Geissier, den er da ununterbrochen und der spuckt, seit wir im Saturn-System sind? Also wie schafft so ein kleiner Mond das? Normalerweise sagt man ja, da ist immer ein Gesteinskern mit dabei. Und das sind radioaktive Elemente drin, so wie auch in der Erde. Und das heizt die ganze Geschichte auf. Also ein kleines Kernkraftwerk. Jeder Planet ist ein kleines Kernkraftwerk. Aber 500 Kilometer Durchmesser, da ist nicht allzu viel Gestein im Inneren. Der Prozentsatz an radioaktiven Elementen ist nicht hoch genug, dass sie sagen können, okay, das ist das, was das Ding aufheizt. Aber was heizt es auf? Und da kommen wir wieder in Wechselwirkungen, wo wir jetzt sagen, wir sind auf einem Feld, da kann man gar nichts mehr sehen, da kann man auch nicht mehr so richtig anfassen. Da reden wir über Gravitation, da reden wir über Anziehungskräfte. Und das ist, glaube ich, die einzig plausible Lösung, um zu erklären, warum so ein kleiner Mond oder wo so ein kleiner Mond seine Energie hernimmt. Und das ist dann große Masse, kleine Masse, gezeiten und Frank Sol kann da bedeutend mehr dazu sagen.
War denn der Enceladus, als er von Cassini beobachtet wurde, da war dieses Phänomen noch unbekannt?
Also, was Cassini erbracht hat, ist die Information, dass sozusagen diese Teilchen aus seinem Inneren, die diesen sogenannten E-Ring versorgen, dass die am Südpol freigesetzt wären, durch diesen Rührvulkanismus, den Ralf Jaumann eben beschrieben hat. Und das Interessante ist, was in Informationen eben auch durch Cassini-Beobachtungen dazu gekommen ist, dass ein Teil dieser Teilchen, die im E-Ring sich befinden, durchaus Spuren von Salz aufweist. Das heißt, die haben eine etwas salzige Zusammensetzung, ein Teil dieser Teilchen. Und dies können wir uns dadurch erklären, dass beispielsweise silikatisches, also Gesteinsmaterial, im Inneren des Mondes im Kontakt ist mit einem flüssigen Reservoir zumindest. Das würde dazu führen, dass solche Partikel eine gewisse salzige Komponente haben, dadurch, dass es eben ausgelaugt wurde, dieses Silikatgestein. Und das führt uns wiederum zu dem Punkt, wie kann so ein kleiner Mond überhaupt, 500 Kilometer Durchmesser haben wir eben gehört, überhaupt so ein flüssiges Reservoir aufrecht erhalten? Und als zusätzliche Wärmequelle kommt hier die sogenannte Zeitenreibung in Betracht. Wir haben eben schon gehört, dass diese Monde gebunden rotieren. Dennoch verändern sie natürlich etwas aufgrund der elliptischen Bahn, den Abstand vom Saturn. Und diese Änderung des Abstandes sorgt dafür, dass der Mond mehr oder weniger durchgewalkt wird. Durch diese periodische Gezeitenwirkung. Die findet auf einer Zeitskala statt des Umlaufs, also auch relativ rasch, von wenigen Tagen. Und die Energie, die dabei freigesetzt wird, sorgt offenbar dafür, dass solche flüssigen Reservare aufrecht erhalten werden können.
Also, dass sie auch flüssig bleiben sozusagen.
Zumindest, wir sind uns nicht darüber im Klaren, ob das jetzt sozusagen eine Art Untergrund-Ozean, der den gesamten Enceladus umspannen würde, erfasst. Die Tendenz geht eher darin, dass es eher konzentriert ist, auf die Südhemisphäre. Diese Entkopplung sozusagen vom tiefen Inneren durch so ein flüssiges Reservoir. Eben da, wo diese vulkanische oder grüovulkanische Aktivität auftritt. Und es ist noch nicht ganz klar, warum sozusagen nur eine Hemisphäre betroffen ist jetzt beim Enceladus. Also, man würde erwarten, schon aus Symmetriegründen, dass sozusagen das gesamte Volumen beansprucht wird.
Weil ja die Gravitation letzten Endes auf alles mehr oder weniger gleichmäßig wirkt.
Richtig, ja. Also ein sehr gutes Beispiel ist natürlich auch im Jupiter-System der vulkanisch aktive Mond Io. Da sehen wir das also ganz, ganz extrem. Welche Auswirkungen die Gezeitenreibung eben machen oder haben kann. Also Io ist der vulkanisch aktivste Mond im Sonnensystem und hat eine vergleichbare vulkanische Aktivität etwa wie die Erde, obwohl er nur die Größe des Mondes besitzt. Das hängt halt damit zusammen, dass der Zentralkörper, in dem Fall der Jupiter oder im Saturn-System der Saturn, eben so massereich sind, wie wir schon gehört haben, dass diese Gezeitenwirkung wesentlich größer ausfällt als beispielsweise im Erde-Mondsystem.
So ein bisschen wie bei so einem Squashball, den man auch erst beim Spiel so richtig auf Thermik bringt, der permanent verformt wird und dadurch heiß wird und dann ja auch erst richtig springt. Also quasi die Monate um den Saturn herum auch die ganze Zeit in Bewegung. Das sind gar nicht so statische, feste, langweilige Körper, sondern die haben da richtig zu leiden.
Zumindest die, die relativ dicht am Saturn sind, weil wir halt wieder eine Schwierigkeit haben. Es gibt nur einen Mond, den Mimas, der umläuft den Saturn noch innerhalb der Enceladus-Bahn. Dort ist eigentlich so gut wie keine Aktivität oder vulkanische Aktivität derzeit zu beobachten. Man würde erwarten, dass er eben ähnlichen Gezeiten, eben Beanspruchungen unterliegt. Das zeigt uns, dass letztlich diese Eismone jeder für sich auch sehr individuell ist. Offensichtlich wurde Mimas einfach nicht warm genug, damit diese Gezeitenreibung einsetzen konnte.
Das ist schon eine sehr spannende Frage. Wenn wir ein Stückchen rausgehen, kommt dann der nächste größere Mond, der wirklich größer ist als Enceladus. Der aber auch nicht dieses Phänomen zeigt. Das heißt also, dieser Prozess der Gezeitenreibung ist sicherlich an einen bestimmten Abstand gebunden, an eine bestimmte Größe gebunden. Also es müssen wieder ganz reif von Zufällen zusammenkommen, damit das überhaupt passieren kann. Und Enceladus war natürlich von Anfang an, also wir haben schon danach gesucht, man hat schon gewusst, dass dort was passieren muss. Normalerweise stellen wir fest, wie alt eine Oberfläche ist, indem wir uns die Einschlagsgrate auf der Oberfläche angucken. Umso länger eine Oberfläche dem Bombardement aus dem Weltraum ausgesetzt ist, dort gibt es Dreck, Körper stoßen zusammen, umso mehr Löcher hat sie auf der Oberfläche. Wenn Sie Enceladus angucken, stellen Sie fest, dass zwar eine Seite ziemlich behakt ist mit solchen Löchern, aber dort, wo dieser Vulkanismus auftritt, dort findet man fast überhaupt keine Einschlagsgrate. Weil das quasi die ganze Zeit regeneriert wird? Das hat man schon bei Voyager gesehen. Man konnte es sich nicht so richtig erklären. Dann ist Enceladus natürlich wahnsinnig hell. Der reflektiert fast 100% des eingestrahlten Sonnenlichts. So wie ein wunderschönes frisches Schneefeld. Das war auch ein Rätsel. Inzwischen weiß man, dass er sich immer wieder beschneit durch das Zeug, das rauskommt. Damit deckt er alle alten Einschlagsgrate dazu. Auf der einen Seite warum er aber ausgerechnet Enceladus tut, und die anderen nicht. Das ist weiterhin noch ein Rätsel, zumindest nicht endgültig geklärt. Das war natürlich spannend, weil wir natürlich auch daran interessiert, immer was zu sehen, wo sich was bewegt, wo man den Prozess noch mit beobachten kann. Was ich am Anfang gesagt habe, ist, wir haben die Oberflächen. Wir sehen die letzte Ergebnis auf der Oberfläche, aber den Prozess selber sehen wir eigentlich meistens nicht. Selbst auf der Erde ist es so, dass ein Vulkanausbruch relativ selten ist. Wenn Sie aber durch die Gebirge wandern, dann sehen Sie überall die Spuren von solchen Vulkanausbrüchen. Ein Geologe kann das alles nachvollziehen, aber er ist natürlich auch daran interessiert, den Prozess selber zu sehen. Das ist bisher eigentlich nur bei Eismonten bei Enceladus gelungen. Wir haben ein paar andere sicher im Verdacht, dass sie das auch tun. Die ganzen großen Jupiter-Monde, Europa, Ganymede, möglicherweise sogar Kalisto haben sowas hinter sich. Wir vermuten das auch bei Titan. Aber direkt zu gucken, dass da was rauskommt und wie es rauskommt und wie es passiert, das kann man nur bei Enceladus. Deswegen ist das natürlich wissenschaftlich eine ganz gewaltige Geschichte, das zu sehen. Vielleicht haben wir auch nur richtig riesiges Glück gehabt. Vielleicht ist der nur alle 100 Millionen Jahre aktiv. Und wir sind gerade dort. Wie er aktiv ist, das wissen wir alles nicht. Wir wissen nur, seit wir dort sind, ist er aktiv. Vielleicht war er auch die letzten 4 Milliarden Jahre aktiv. Das sind natürlich jetzt die Fragen, die wieder offen geblieben sind. Vielleicht sehen wir auch nur noch die letzte Phase. Vielleicht sehen wir es nur am Südpol deshalb, weil es langsam zusammenschrumpft und irgendwann aufhört. Dann haben wir Glück gehabt, dass wir jetzt dort sind. Und nicht erst in 100, 200, 300 Jahren, wenn es nicht mehr passiert. Okay, aber das gehört dazu. Ohne Glück kriegt man auch in der Wissenschaft nichts raus.
Wo wir schon mal bei den Monden sind, wir sollten auf jeden Fall auch noch mal auf Saturn als Seuchen zu sprechen kommen. Es gibt ja derer eine ganze Menge, also haben wir es ja angesprochen. Keiner hat so viele wie der Saturn und es sind glaube ich über 60. Wobei die allermeisten jetzt wirklich zu vernachlässigen sind. Also das sind sehr kleine Objekte.
Es gibt verschiedene Klassen. Wir haben die ganz kleinen, wir haben die mittleren und wir haben den ganz großen, das ist Titan. Also er bietet alles sozusagen an. Und alle haben ihre besondere Besonderheit, alle haben auch ihre Aufgabe, die ganz kleinen Wechselwirken mit den Ringen. Ich hab vorhin schon gesagt, es gibt die, zumindest bei der enkischen Teilung, kann man das direkt nachvollziehen, warum in den Ringen dieses Loch ist. Denn genau dort fliegt ein Mond durch.
Also enkische Teilung ist jetzt eine bestimmte Lücke im Ringsystem.
Genau. Die kann man auch von der Erde aus sehen. Das ist die äußere Lücke. Die innere Lücke ist die cassinische Teilung. Bei der enkischen Teilung sieht man, dass da ein kleiner Mond durchfliegt. Das heißt also der, wie ein Schneeräumer, der räumt sozusagen die Ringpartikel weg, weil die Gravitationskraft dieses Mondes sorgt dafür, dass die einen Ringpartikel nach außen beschleunigt werden und die anderen nach innen beschleunigt werden. Er macht sich so Platz und fliegt rum.
Da hat man im Prinzip wieder genau diese Analogie zum Sonnensystem als solchen. Alle unsere Planeten sind deshalb Planeten, weil sie genau diese Freiräumaktivität vermocht haben. Der Pluto ist ja degradiert worden, genau weil er eben da nicht ausreichend hat wegschaufeln können. Und da an dem Ringsystem kann man das quasi direkt sehen.
Das ist die kleine Welt, wo Sie im Kleinen nachvollziehen können, wie es wahrscheinlich im Großen vorher auch passiert ist.
War das der Wissenschaft eigentlich schon immer klar?
Das mit dem Ringsystem ist eine ganz nette Geschichte. Man hat es immer vermutet, hat aber eigentlich erst zehn Jahre nach den Voyager-Daten, in den Voyager-Daten, den Mondpan gefunden. Der war die ganze Zeit da, man hat es immer übersehen. Und ein Kollege hat seine Doktorarbeit darüber geschrieben, der hat zehn Jahre, nachdem die großen Wissenschaftler eigentlich mit dem Ringsystem schon fertig waren, hat er noch den Mondpan gefunden. Das heißt, man sieht, dass die Datenmenge ist so komplex und die Dinge sind so verzwickt, dass man ziemlich lange Zeit braucht, um wirklich hinter die Geheimnisse zu kommen. Andererseits sieht man auch, dass es nicht so ist, dass man da einfach mal vorbeifliegt und dann gucken die Wissenschaftler auf die Daten und dann haben sie alles erforscht. Die Datenmenge bei solchen Missionen ist so groß, dass sie eigentlich für ein paar Generationen reicht. Man kann auch, wenn man nicht von Anfang an dabei war, sondern ein bisschen später geboren ist, noch große Entdeckungen machen.
Zumal man ja auch immer bessere Werkzeuge hat um das Ganze auch zu analysieren. Mit den Computern vor 20 Jahren war das noch was ganz anderes als mit den Wolkencomputern von heute. Aber der ist ja auch wirklich klein. Ich sehe gerade so 35 Kilometer. Also das ist wirklich ein Staubkorn im Vergleich.
Na, der ist schon noch relativ groß. Cassini ist jetzt runter bis auf unter einem Kilometer. Also Monde, die kleiner sind als ein Kilometer, werden zumindest momentan noch entdeckt.
Also es kommen sogar noch welche dazu.
Es gibt immer noch ein bisschen, was er jetzt langsam nachwählt. Jetzt sind wir schon so richtig durch. Jetzt haben wir Grunde alles gesehen.
Irgendwann ist natürlich auch die Frage, wann ist es ein Mond und wann ist es einfach nur so ein...
Staubkorn, das ist richtig. Aber da ist schon nochmal ein Unterschied dazwischen. Das heißt also, die größten Brocken im System selber, sie sind so im 10er-Meter-Bereich. Also im Ringsystem selber sind im 10er-Meter-Bereich. Und dann, was so ein Kilometer groß ist, ist dann schon noch ein Mond. Okay, es gibt eine ganze Reihe von anderen verrückten Dingen. Wenn man die anschaut, gibt es zwei Monde, die fliegen ganz dicht nebeneinander. Und wenn Sie die Bahnen und die Durchmesser genau anschauen, dann stellen Sie fest, dass die Bahnen so dicht beieinander sind, dass die eigentlich zusammenstoßen müssten, weil die Bahnen dichter zusammenliegen als die Durchmesser. Und der eine fliegt innen, der andere außen. Und so wie das halt ist, der innen ist ein bisschen schneller als der außeren. Der holt den dann auch irgendwann ein und müsste dann eigentlich, die müssten zusammenstoßen. Genau das tun sie nicht, weil kurz bevor sie zusammenstoßen, beschleunigt der innere den äußeren und der äußere bremst den inneren ab. Und die wechseln die Bahn. Und das machen sie, ich weiß nicht wann, alle vier Jahre. Und dadurch vermeiden sie, dass sie zusammenstoßen. Also es gibt äußerst verrückte Geschichten.
Wie heißen die beiden?
In diesem System.
Haben wir auch gleich eine passende Benennung bekommen. Da gehen aber ja schon fast die Namen aus bei so vielen Monden. Wer denkt sich die denn eigentlich immer wieder aus? Was macht man eigentlich, wenn irgendwann mal die ganzen Götter durchgezählt sind?
Ah nee, da gibt es jede Menge Wissenschaftler, die man dann auch noch beirren kann.
Das geht nicht so einfach. Erstens müssen die tot sein. Und zweitens, nein, das was man gemacht hat, ist man geht natürlich her und versucht schon bestimmte Nomenklaturen festzusetzen. Also Saturn ist ein auf jeden Fall römischer Gott. Man hat also die ganze Mythologie erstmal bemüht. Auf jeden Fall versucht man natürlich bestimmte Dinge zu finden. Jetzt sagt man für die Oberflächen Merkmale, Einschlagskrater und andere Dinge, die man auf einzelnen Monden findet, hat man sich dann was zusammen genommen, hat gesagt, okay, wir nehmen bestimmte Literatur. Ich weiß jetzt nicht bei welchem Mond das war. Dann nimmt man sozusagen die König-Arthus-Geschichte und dann kommen die Namen da alle zusammen. Oder man nimmt 1000 und eine Nacht. Und dann dürfen für die Oberfläche, für die Einschlagskrater, alles, was man dort findet, eben nur Namen aus dieser elementaren Literatur genommen werden. Also man ist nicht frei und kann sagen, ich benenne das jetzt sozusagen nach meiner Freundin, die Zeiten sind längst vorbei, das ist nicht mehr erlaubt.
Gut, also es gibt verschiedene Mondklassen. Vieles ist recht klein. Die haben ja auch alle nicht mehr so richtig die Größe, um überhaupt richtig rund zu sein. Das sind eigentlich auch mehr so herumfliegende Gesteinsbrocken, machen eigentlich mehr so Asteroiden. Was ich vorhin noch so ein bisschen als Selbstverständlichkeit rausgehört habe, ist so, alles ist irgendwie eisbedeckt. Ist denn das jetzt normal da im Saturn-Bereich, dass irgendwie alles Eis hat, oder könnte nicht auch einfach da nur ein Stein rumfliegen, wie das so im Asteroidengürtel auch der Fall ist?
Eher nicht, denn alles, was wir außerhalb von 2,5 astronomischen Einheiten haben, das ist ungefähr die Mitte des Asteroidengürtels, ist Eis. Alles, was innerhalb ist, da ist zu warm für Eis, abgesehen von Sonderbedingungen auf der Erde oder auf dem Mars.
Aber es ist ja nicht nur Eis.
Aber die Krusten sind zum größten Teil Eis. All diese Körper sind, ich sag jetzt mal ganz frech, aus einem Drittel Gestein und aus zwei Dritteln Eis ungefähr aufgebaut.
Bis zu 50% Eis, 50% Gestein etwa beim Enceladus und auch beim Titan.
Nur flüssige Zustand von Wasser ist da ausgesprochen selten.
Ja gut, das ist aber genau das, was wir gesehen haben. Was wir im Grunde haben, wir haben immer arktische Verhältnisse. Wir haben irgendwo eine Gesteinsoberfläche, dann haben wir da drüber Eis und unter bestimmten Bedingungen, vielleicht sogar in sehr vielen Fällen, haben wir zwischen der Gesteinsoberfläche und der Eiskruste Temperaturbedingungen, die um die Null Grad liegen oder etwas drüber und dann hätten wir dort einen Ozean. Und das ist natürlich, ja, ich glaube schon, dass das auch eine Erkenntnis von Cassini ist und dass das auch von der Galileo-Mission und das uns schon ein bisschen erstaunt hat, dass das weit häufiger vorkommt, als wir ursprünglich gedacht haben. Viele diese Körper zeigen, zum Beispiel Ganymede, der Mond im Saturn-System, der hat ein Magnetfeld. Und im Magnetfeld brauchen sie natürlich irgendwas, was leitet und brauchen wieder eine Flüssigkeit, damit das funktioniert. Das heißt also, es scheint schon sehr, es scheint schon ein Prozess zu sein, der relativ häufig vorkommt. Und wir wissen nicht, wie viel der anderen Monde das letztlich auch haben, die vielleicht eine viel dickere Eiskruste haben, sodass die Wechselwirkung zwischen der Eiskruste und der Oberfläche nicht so dominant ist wie zum Beispiel bei Enceladus. Okay, aber das würde heißen, da draußen hat man Wasser auch zumindest in zwei Aggregatszuständen. Und auch im Flüssigen. Und das wirft schon einen Blick, gibt schon einen neuen Blick auf die Möglichkeiten in unserem Sonnensystem. Das sage ich jetzt nicht für uns, aber möglicherweise fürs Leben. Denn unter so einer Eiskruste kann durchaus was passiert sein.
Es kommt auch hinzu, wenn wir berücksichtigen, dass das Saturn-System etwa zehnmal so weit ist von der Sonne entfernt ist wie die Erde, dass die Temperaturen eben so niedrig sind dort, dass eben auch Eise kondensieren können oder Substanzen kondensieren können mit einem wesentlich geringeren Schmelzpunkt als Wassereis beispielsweise. Ich denke da an Ammoniak. Von Methan haben wir auch schon gehört, aber ich denke insbesondere an Ammoniak. Da gibt es auch Indizien dafür, dass das zumindest im Inneren eingebaut ist. Von diesen Monden, insbesondere beim Titan, könnte das eine Rolle spielen, um den Schmelzpunkt des Eises so weit herabzusetzen, nämlich um fast 100°C, dass tatsächlich bei den niedrigen Temperaturen solche Untergrundozeane stabil bleiben können. Also wir reden dann bei Mischungen aus Ammoniak und Wasser. Von Schmelztemperaturen, die liegen etwa bei minus 100°C. Und da wär's flüssig. Und dann kommt hinzu, dass wenn wir darüber die Eiskruste haben, dass die Eiskruste auch so eine Art Isolationswirkung, zusätzliche Isolationswirkung hat. Auf die Art und Weise ist es auch möglich, dass solche flüssigen Reservare über längere Zeiträume hin stabil bleiben. Und wenn dann noch eine zusätzliche Energiequelle auftritt, zum Beispiel die radioaktive Wärmeproduktion durch diese Gesteinsphase oder die zusätzliche Aufheizung durch Gezeiten, kann auch bei Titan eine große Rolle spielen, da die Exzentrizität der Bahn recht ausgeprägt ist. Dann sind sozusagen diese Bedingungen erfüllt, dass über längere, auch geologische Zeiträume hinweg eben solche flüssigen Untergrundreservare mit ihrer entsprechenden Bedeutung für die Bewohnbarkeit aufrechterhalten werden können.
Aber aufrechterhalten heißt ja immer so, man freut sich schon, wenn es nicht mehr weggeht. Die Frage ist natürlich vor allem erstmal, wie ist überhaupt dazu gekommen? Mal jetzt vielleicht mal so ein bisschen mal zurückspulen in der Zeit. Irgendwann hat sich halt das ganze Sonnensystem herausgebildet. Der Saturn ist quasi der Freiräumer in der Bahn. Hat sich halt alles Mögliche an Material einverleibt. Diese Monde sind dann vermute ich mal schon auch zum frühen Zeitpunkt da, haben die sich von sich ausgebildet oder wurden irgendwie freigeschossen. Jetzt spricht man immer vom Gasplaneten. Der besteht ja nicht nur aus Gas, oder? Hat das wirklich einen festen Kern? Oder ist es wirklich nur so eine Gaswolke, die so vor sich hin wabert? Ich finde den Begriff so ein bisschen verirrend. Was ist denn derzeit der Blick darauf, wie sich dieses Saturnsystem wirklich entwickelt hat?
Eine große Frage ist, ob diese Gasriesen, Saturn und Jupiter, tatsächlich über einen festen Kern verfügen. Das weiß man jetzt momentan noch nicht. Es ist gerade eine Mission unterwegs, die Juno-Mission, die genau dieser Frage im Saturnsystem nachgehen möchte und herausbekommen möchte, ob es da tatsächlich einen festen Kern gibt, der als eine Art Aggressionskeim sozusagen dienen konnte, das anschließend in der Frühphase als genug Gas vorhanden war im äußeren Sonnensystem.
Juno ist auf dem Weg zum Jupiter.
Ja, ganz genau, auf dem Weg zum Jupiter. Und Ähnliches gilt auch für Saturn. Ich hatte vorhin gesagt, dass der relativ schnell rotiert, dementsprechend auch stark abgeplattet ist. Aus dieser Figur des rasch rotierenden Saturn lassen sich Informationen über die Masseverteilung in seinem Inneren gewinnen. Und aus der chemischen Zusammensetzung der äußeren Schichten lassen sich ja Rückschlüsse eben auf die Chemie des Inneren ziehen. Im Wesentlichen sind es Wasserstoff und Helium, aus denen die aufgebaut sind. Aber mit zunehmendem Druck und Temperatur im Inneren nimmt das Material dort andere Aggregatzustände an. Und im Endeffekt entspricht der Zustand im tiefen Inneren der Gasriesen. Also die können so weit zunehmen, dass das letztlich eben auch, also Druck und Temperatur können so weit zunehmen, dass das Material letztlich auch ganz spezielle ionisierte Zustände übergehen kann. Und jetzt nicht mehr vergleichbar ist mit dem, was wir jetzt von den Oberflächen unserer restlichen Planeten, beispielsweise, kennen.
Aber ich meine, Wasserstoff und Helium, das haben wir ja schon mal gehört. Also eigentlich ist ja so unser Turn auch nur eine verhinderte Sonne.
Ja, ich meine, es gibt noch einen anderen Hinweis darauf, dass möglicherweise die Sache im Inneren etwas dichteres Material enthält. Und das ist letztlich die Dichte, also Masse und Volumen. Aber wenn ich nur Wasserstoff und Helium nehme, dann kriege ich es meistens nicht hin. Also es muss schon noch irgendwas da sein. Also die Theorie sagt, dass die Körpergesteinskerne, also silikatische Kerne haben.
Ja, aber der physikalische Zustand, also das ist, man kann dann eigentlich nicht mehr von Eis reden, oder von Gestein reden und von Gas reden. Das ist sozusagen in so einem fluiden Zustand dann.
Wird denn diese Juno-Sonde, also wie geht sie denn dem Jupiter da auf den Leib? Wird sie sich da hinein stürzen, oder was ist da die Idee?
Also Juno wird insbesondere eben in den Orbit gehen und einen polaren Orbit und dementsprechend Messungen, hochgenaue präzise Messungen des Schwerfeldes vornehmen, um eben speziell diese Frage zu beantworten.
Also Klartext, was ist die Gravitation und letztlich auch der Frage, was ist die Masse von dem Körper, näher zu kommen.
Und daraus wird man sich das schon ableiten können, vermutet man, hofft man, wie es im Inneren beschaffen ist?
Das hängt davon ab, wie genau, mit welcher Genauigkeit, mit welcher Präzision die verschiedenen räumlichen Skalen dieses Magnetfelds erfasst werden. Oder die Gravitationsfeldes erfasst werden können.
Aber grundsätzlich ist, also die Betrachtung richtig, es ist im Wesentlichen Gas. Also man hat einfach eine große Menge an Gas. Zum größten Teil.
Das sind zwei verhinderte Sonnen, die nicht so groß geworden sind, dass der innere Druck zur Fusion gereicht hätte. Oder die Temperatur im Inneren zur Fusion gereicht hätte.
Ja, richten wir doch mal unseren Blick auf Titan. Das ist ja so ein bisschen der Superstar. Ist ja schon angeklungen. Dadurch, dass dort so eine aktive Atmosphäre vorherrscht, kam es dann letzten Endes auch zu Huygens Missionen, die ja sehr erfolgreich abgeschlossen wurde, wie wir hier vor zwei Sendungen schon mal gehört haben. Vielleicht für die, die auch da noch nicht reingehört haben. Also Cassini und Huygens, Huygens dann Huckepack, sind eben ins Saturnsystem geflogen. Dann ist Cassini relativ nah an den Titan rangeflogen. Das haben wir auch noch gehört. Das passiert am laufenden Meter. Aber dann gab es eben diesen speziellen Moment des Abwurfs. Dann ist Huygens in die Atmosphäre eingetreten, bis auf den Boden niedergegangen und hat, solange es irgendwie möglich war, gefunkt. Und das, was noch innerhalb bestimmten Zeitraums von Cassini empfangen worden konnte und wurde dann entsprechend weitergeleitet an die Erde, das ist das wissenschaftliche Rohmaterial, was gewonnen werden konnte. Jetzt war Huygens mit einer Vielzahl von Sensoren ausgerüstet. Hören, gucken, schmecken war alles irgendwie dabei. Wie weit ist man denn vorangekommen durch Huygens? Wie stellt sich der Titan jetzt der Wissenschaft dar?
Also, man muss mal sagen, das Huygens war eigentlich ursprünglich gedacht als Sonde, die die Titan-Atmosphäre untersuchen sollte. Man ist die Atmosphäre eingetaucht, es ist ein Fallschirm aufgegangen, man ist durch die Atmosphäre geflogen und hat in der Atmosphäre gemessen. Man hatte die Hoffnung, dass man auf der Oberfläche aufkommt und dass man dann auch noch etwas über die Oberfläche erfährt. Das war aber nicht das ursprüngliche Ziel, sondern wirklich die Atmosphäre. Man hat ganz am Schluss noch so ein Oberflächenmesspaket dazu gepackt und war ein voller Erfolg, ist durch die Atmosphäre gegangen, ist auf der Oberfläche aufgekommen, hat auf der Oberfläche auch noch gemessen, hat auch noch viel länger gemessen als Cassini sozusagen im Funkkontakt stand. Und nicht nur ich, sondern eine ganze Reihe von Wissenschaftlern sind richtig traurig gewesen. Wir wussten, der misst auf der Oberfläche noch und Cassini war dann aus dem Funkkontakt raus. dort sind jede Menge Daten noch erzeugt worden, die wir nie gesehen haben und nie sehen werden. Die große Frage war, was passiert denn, wenn er auf der Oberfläche aufkommt? Wir haben Temperaturen von minus 180 Grad, 190 Grad. Dort wird Methan flüssig. man hat damit gerechnet, dass man möglicherweise in einem Methansee landet. Wusste das aber nicht. Man ist nicht in einem Methansee gelandet, aber die Kamera hat noch ein paar Aufnahmen geschossen von der Gegend und auch von der Oberfläche und sehe da. Man ist in einer Gegend gelandet. Wenn Sie es einfach so angucken und auf der Erde, selbst bei den schlechten Sichtverhältnissen wegen der dichten Atmosphäre betrachten würden, würden Sie sagen, wir sind in einem Flussbett gelandet. Dort liegen Brocken rum, was immer das ist. Wir können bis heute nicht eindeutig feststellen, ob das Wassereis ist oder ob es was anderes ist. Die sind richtig schön rund. Die müssen also mal bewegt worden sein und durch gegenseitiges Reiben so richtig schön rund geworden sein, so wie Kieselsteine bei uns in unseren Flüssen. Man hat in der Umgebung eine ganze Menge Dinge festgestellt, wie man gelandet ist oder bevor man gelandet ist, wer die Kamera konnte, die Umgebung sehen, hatte sogar einen Scheinwerfer dabei. Man hat gesehen, dass man am Rand des Flustals, das ist ein sehr breites Flustal, wo man gelandet ist, einen Höhenzug gesehen hat. In dem Höhenzug waren eingeschnitten sehr viele Täler. Und zwar Täler, die, wir nennen das den Trittisch, das heißt also ein Muster zeigen, wo sich ein kleiner Rindsal zu einem Bächlein und die viele Bächlein dann zu einem Flüsslein und viele Flüsslein zu einem Fluss zusammentun. Das ist ein eindeutiger Hinweis, zumindest auf der Erde, dass das Zeug nicht aus dem Untergrund kommen kann, sondern dass das von oben kommen muss und sich dann auf der Oberfläche sammelt, so wie bei uns, wenn es regnet. Somit war eigentlich die groben Rahmenbedingungen schon gesetzt. Man hat zwar den Ozean nicht gefunden, den man postuliert hat, zumindest hat Huygens den Ozean nicht gefunden, den man postuliert hat. Aber man hat gesehen, dass es dort eine ganz klare Wechselwirkung zwischen der Atmosphäre und der Oberfläche gibt. Und dass sozusagen das Medium, das diese Wechselwirkung betreibt, Methan ist. Und Methan eben in der Form, dass es verdampft, dass es als Wolken in die Atmosphäre geht, dass es zu Konzentrationen kommt, dass es dann wieder ausregnet, dass es dann flüssig über die Oberfläche läuft und wahrscheinlich dann irgendwo versickert oder sich findet. Insofern war das natürlich schon eine ganz gewaltige Sensation, die man da rausgekriegt hat. Die paar Spektralenmessungen, die man gemacht hat, gesehen, dass man nicht so eindeutig Eis auf der Oberfläche nachweisen kann, aber das ist jetzt ein bisschen schwierig, weil dieses Methan ist natürlich, ja, wenn das dann in der Atmosphäre ausflockt, dann gibt es so einen richtig dreckigen, organischen Brei, der dann runter regnet und der alles zudeckt. Jetzt mit den Instrumenten, die man hat, auch aus dem Orbit, kann man natürlich immer nur die direkte Oberfläche messen. Wenn Sie also einen Eisbrocken haben und da liegt so ein bisschen, ja, wie wir sagen, ich will nicht Teeartige, aber so ein bisschen dunkles, dreckiges Zeug drüber, dann messen Sie natürlich ununterbrochen das Methan oder noch höhere Kohlenwasserstoffe, aber Sie sehen, darunter liegen der Eis nicht. Und das ist eigentlich der Zustand, den wir bis heute haben. Was dann danach passiert ist, sind ein paar Dinge, die äußerst interessant waren. Cassini hat ein Radargerät an Bord, das durch die Atmosphäre schauen kann. Dieses Radargerät hat immer wieder Stellen gefunden, wo kaum ein Radarsignal zurückkam. Und normalerweise reflektieren Flüssigkeiten kein Radarsignal. Das ist aber auch wieder schwer zu sagen, weil es eben zweideutig ist. Es können auch andere Dinge eintreten. Es kann einfach eine relativ glatte oder ebene Fläche sein, die reflektiert auch kein Radarsignal. Das hat man ein bisschen lang gebraucht, um herauszukriegen, was diese Flächen waren. Interessanterweise waren in der Nordhalbkugel bedeutend mehr dieser dunklen Radarflächen als in der Südhalbkugel. Das ganze Saturn-System ist geneigt gegenüber der Ägyptik, so wie die Erde auch. Damit ist Titan auch geneigt. Damit gibt es im Saturn-System Jahreszeiten. Und auf Titan auch. Die Jahreszeiten momentan sind so, dass in der Nord-Temisphäre Winter ist und in der Süd-Temisphäre Sommer ist. Jetzt ist es aber so, dass die Jahreszeiten natürlich keine Jahreszeiten sind im Sinne von unserem Jahr, sondern von der Umlaufzeit. Und 30 Jahre braucht Saturn, bis er einmal um die Sonne ist. Das heißt also, eine Jahreszeit dort dauert 15 Jahre. Wir sind jetzt gerade mal 10 Jahre dort. Das heißt also, wir sind immer in derselben Jahreszeit. Immer noch Winter im Norden und Sommer im Süden. Man hat die Cassini-Mission hauptsächlich deshalb verlängert, weil man von einer Jahreszeit in die andere gehen will. Und da sind wir jetzt. Und das ist jetzt genau der Umbruch, der passiert. Also wir gehen jetzt sozusagen vom nördlichen Winter in den nördlichen Frühling. Was man aber festgestellt hat, bei einer dieser wenigen dunklen Flächen in der Südpöhlregion, die auch den Namen Ontario Lacus bekommen hat, also Ontario See, weil er genauso aussieht wie der amerikanische Ontario See, den hat man inzwischen sehr gut vermessen, einmal mit Radar und zum anderen Spektral. Und siehe da, man konnte nachweisen über die spektralen Daten, dass dort Restflüssigkeit drin ist. Also, man kann Methan nicht direkt als Restflüssigkeit nachweisen, weil Methan ist überall, das ist in der Atmosphäre und sie können das nicht so richtig auseinanderhalten. Man hat aber durchaus beweisen können, dass Ethan drin ist. Das heißt also die nächsthöhere Stufe von Kohlenwasserstoffen, also CH4, dann C2H2 und man hat inzwischen auch nachgewiesen, dass im Grunde genommen die ganze Palette da ist. Also alles, was wir so von unseren Kohlenwasserstoffen kennen. Wir können Kohlenwasserstoffe aus der Erde in erster Linie von Erdöl und wir haben im Grunde genommen bis Benzol und bis noch höher alle Kohlenwasserstoffe auch auf Titan vorhanden. Das war der erste Hinweis, war noch eigentlich ein Hinweis in der Spektralsignatur, dass dieses Ethan flüssig sein muss. Und dann ist es immer ein bisschen besser geworden, das Wetter. Heißt, wenn im Norden Winter ist, sind dort auch die Wolken. Also man kann da zwar mit Radar durchschauen, aber nicht mit den optischen Instrumenten. Aber die optischen Instrumente können natürlich die spektrale Zusammensetzung messen. Und dann ist es gelungen, man hat es auch geplant, wie die Wolkenschichten oder das Wetter besser geworden ist im Norden mal den Versuch zu unternehmen, ob man Spiegelreflektion sehen kann. Das ist das, was wir bei uns haben, wenn die Sonne zum Beispiel aufs Meer scheint. Und Sie betrachten das Meer mit genau dem gleichen Winkel, mit dem die Sonne drauf scheint. Dann sehen Sie, spiegelt sich die Sonne im Meer oder in einem See oder in einem Fluss oder was Sie auch immer haben. Das sieht man oft, wenn man im Flugzeug sitzt. Manchmal, wenn schöne Tage im Winter sind, können Sie es auch auf der Straße sehen, wenn die nass ist. Sie fahren hin und die Sonne steht relativ tief. Und so tief, wie Sie in Ihrem Auto sitzen, dann kriegen Sie auch Spiegelreflektion. Dann sind Sie geblendet. Das Spielchen hat man gemacht. Man fliegt mit dem Raumschiff so über den Nordpol, dass man einen Zeitpunkt erwischt, wo die Sonne so steht, dass der Einfallswinkel und Ausfallswinkel gleich sind. Das hat man vor zwei Jahren gemacht. Und die Dame hat eine Spiegelreflektion entdeckt. Das kann man natürlich nicht im Sichtband tun, weil da die Atmosphäre dicht ist, aber man kann es im Infraroten tun. Im Infraroten ist sie durchlässig.
Also man hat jetzt genau auf diesen Ontario-Lakus gezielt.
Nicht Ontario, sondern im Norden. Kraken-Mare heißt das. Das ist ein viel größeres. Er hat damit nachgewiesen, dass dieses Ding rada schwarz ist, aber auch mit Flüssigkeit gefüllt ist. Inzwischen wissen wir, dass es nicht nur diese eine Stelle, wo wir die Spiegelreflektion gemessen haben, gibt, sondern dass es sehr, sehr viele größere zusammenhängende Seen und Meere gibt, die mit Methan gefüllt sind in der Nordhalbkugel. Und jetzt ist es wahrscheinlich so, das ist die Annahme und das soll bis 2017 auch nochmal überprüft werden. Jetzt ist es so, dass natürlich auf der Südhalbkugel ist es Sommer und ist das Wetter gut, ist nicht sehr viel Methan in der Atmosphäre. Die Seen dort sind ausgetrocknet bis auf ein paar Pfützen. Und in der Nordhalbkugel gibt es ganz viele, dort regnet es ununterbrochen, nämlich Methan. Und da sind die Seen noch gefüllt. Und jetzt ist natürlich die spannende Frage, was passiert, wenn sich das Wetter ändert. Das heißt also, wenn die Methanwolken auf die Südhalbkugel gehen, dann fängt natürlich die Nordhalbkugel an auszutrocknen. Und es müsste in der Südhalbkugel regnen, Methan. Und das ist eine sehr gute, spannende Frage. Die zweite Frage, die damit zusammenhängt, ist, wir sehen keine dieser Seen in der Äquatorgegend. Aber wir sehen riesige Dünenfelder in der Äquatorgegend. Also so ähnlich wie bei uns, dass die Sahara dort ist. Und das muss auch irgendwo herkommen, dieses Dünenmaterial. Das sind natürlich jetzt keine Quarzkörner, sondern das sind wahrscheinlich organische Verbindungen, Eiskörnchen. Aber bei der Erde ist es so, dass der Sand auf der Erde entsteht durch Mechanische Zerkleinerung, bei der immer Wasser beteiligt ist. Entweder in Flüssen oder an Küsten mit dem Meer. Und die Dünen, die auf der Erde entstehen, sind nichts anderes als dieses zerkleinerte Material, das im Strandbereich von Meeren entsteht. Weil die Meer sind, sehen Sie, da ist überall Sand. Und das ist nichts anderes als die Wellen, die ununterbrauchendes Gestein so klein hauen, dass zum Schluss nur noch die ganz harten, kleinen Quarzkörnchen da übrig bleiben. Die ganze Sahara besteht aus dem, heißt im Klartext, da wo heute Sahara ist, muss mal ganz viel mehr gewesen sein früher. Okay, jetzt ist die spannende Frage natürlich, was ist da auf dem Titan passiert? Denn es geht so ein richtiger Gürtel von Dünen einmal um den Äquator. Also dieses Material muss zerkleinert worden sein, auch wieder durch so einen Prozess. Wir haben aber kein Wasser dort, das das tun kann, also kann es nur das flüssige Methan getan haben. Wir haben sicherlich auch kein Gestein dort, sondern wir haben wahrscheinlich eine Eisoberfläche. Also ist es wahrscheinlich Eis in erster Näherung, das dort zerkleinert wurde. Möglicherweise sind es auch feste Partikel, die mit dem Methan aus der Atmosphäre ausregnen.
Also Dünen aus Eiskristallen.
Dünen aus Eiskristallen und auch aus gefrorenen anderen. Wie Frank Solz schon gesagt hat, wir sind da draußen so kalt, dass nicht nur Eis gefriert, sondern auch andere Gase gefrieren.
Absurd, aber es ist interessant zu sehen, dass man wirklich so eine totale Analogie hat zur Erde, obwohl es eigentlich komplett anders ist.
Man kann sagen, das Spannende oder das wirkliche Erkenntnis an dieser Geschichte ist, Geologie funktioniert immer gleich. Ganz egal, was sie benutzen. Ob sie Gestein benutzen und Wasser benutzen oder ob sie Eis benutzen und flüssiges Methan benutzen, es kommt immer das Gleiche raus. Sie kriegen Dünen, sie kriegen Flusssysteme, sie kriegen Meere, sie kriegen Küsten. Und das ist natürlich schon eine spannende Geschichte. Und wahrscheinlich, wenn man noch weiter rausgeht und wenn man irgendwann bei Pluto anfängt zu gucken, dann findet man dort Gase, die bei 40 Grad Kelvin genau das Gleiche tun wie Methan bei 90 Kelvin.
Was ist denn so für den Planetenphysiker aus der Huygens-Mission rausgekommen?
Sehr interessant an der Huygens-Mission sind auch die Informationen, die man bezüglich der chemischen Zusammensetzung erhalten hat. Beispielsweise war es möglich, die Isotopensignatur speziell von Kohlenwasserstoffverbindungen besser einzugrenzen. Insbesondere Kohlenstoff und auch Stickstoff. Wir hatten ja schon erwähnt, die Titan-Atmosphäre besteht zum überwiegenden Teil aus Stickstoff, mit etwa 5% Beimengung an Methan. Aus den verschiedenen Stickstoff-Isotopen und den Kohlenstoff-Isotopen hinzu kommt, dass noch Argon nachgewiesen werden konnte, hat man gelernt, dass die Atmosphäre, wohl zumindest ein Teil der Atmosphäre, relativ spät durch Entgasung, Ausgasung des Innern entstanden ist. Und das wirft natürlich schon auch Fragen auf, wie das Innere generell beschaffen ist. Und in den letzten Jahren, aufgrund dieser zahlreichen Vorbeiflüge der Cassini-Raumsonde am Titan, ist es möglich gewesen, auch das Schwerefeld besser zu vermessen. Und man hat festgestellt, dass das Innere weniger stark zum Zentrum hin, also die Masse im Inneren weniger stark zum Zentrum hin konzentriert ist, als man das erwarten würde, wenn beispielsweise Titan vollkommen aufgeschmolzen gewesen wäre in der Vergangenheit und so eine klassische Struktur bestehend aus dem Kern einem Gesteinsmantel und einer Eismülle aufgebaut hätte. Es sieht eher danach aus, dass nach diesen Schwerefeldmessungen, dass eben das Innere nur im Inneren teilweise diese Trennung von Gestein und Eis stattgefunden hat. Das heißt also, dass das Innere gar nicht so stark in der Vergangenheit aufgeheizt wurde, dass diese Trennung vollständig gewesen ist. Es ist mehr so ein Gemisch, kann man sich das vorstellen, zumindest in dem Inneren Bereich. Was nicht heißt, dass eben außen in den äußeren Bereichen durchaus diese Trennung, diese Entmischung stärker gewesen ist. Aber das Interessante ist halt, es sagt uns, dass offensichtlich doch eine ganze Menge noch an solchen flüchtigen Gestandteilen, diesen volatilen Substanzen im Inneren enthalten sind. Wir müssen uns auch vor Augen halten, dass das Methan auch nicht besonders lang in der Atmosphäre überleben kann. Das muss immer wieder aus dem Inneren sozusagen nachgeliefert werden, weil in den höheren Atmosphären Stockwerken eben durch die Einstrahlung des Sonnenlichtes das Methan aufgespalten wird und entsprechend höhere, also aus den Bestandteilen höhere Aerosole aufgebaut werden, die dann wieder abregnen, sich an der Oberfläche sammeln können, beispielsweise auch an den Seen, in denen in den Seen niedergehen können. Und Wasserstoff würde dann entweichen. Das heißt, es muss generell aus dem Inneren nach, müssen große Mengen an Methan nachgeliefert werden. Und ich denke, eine Frage ist auch momentan, wo sind diese Quellen? Gibt es eventuell an der Oberfläche Hinweise darauf, wie das Methan sozusagen aus dem Inneren dann in die Atmosphäre eingespeist werden kann?
Eigentlich muss das ganze Material im Rahmen des Freiräums, der Staubschicht entstanden sein. Also Titan hat sich eben einfach bedient aus all dem, was den Saturn so umkreist hat, bzw. vielleicht auch zum selben Zeitpunkt entstanden. Da müsste ja eigentlich das Methan schon dabei gewesen sein, oder hat sich das später erst gebildet. Ich frage mich jetzt nur gerade, warum ist jetzt nur der Titan so und nicht alle anderen Monde auch? Die haben sich ja im Prinzip alle mehr oder weniger aus demselben Material Urstoff ernährt und müssten ja von daher dann auch alle diese Fähigkeit haben, theoretisch zumindest, offensichtlich liegt noch was anderes vor, auszudünsten und sich selber so eine Atmosphäre zuzulegen. Warum haben nicht alle so eine Atmosphäre? Warum muss man da eine bestimmte Größe haben? Wie erklärt sich das?
Größe ist eine Erklärung. Sie müssen so viel Gravitation haben, dass sie diese Gasmoleküle halten können. Selbst wenn es die anderen hatten vorher, verschwinden die natürlich. Wir sehen bei den Blumps, bei den geiseartigen Ausbrüchen, bei Enceladus, dass das ganze Zeug da ja auch mit rauskommt. Wir sehen dort CO2, wir sehen Kohlenmonoxid, wir sehen Methan, wir sehen Ethan. Das bleibt aber nicht dort, weil der ist so klein, dass er die...
Er hält es nicht und gibt es einfach ins System ab.
Das verliert sich dann und Titan ist groß genug. Titan ist größer als Merkur, glaube ich. Also er ist schon ein guter Brocken, der das halten kann. Wir könnten natürlich sofort die Frage stellen, und die müsste man auch stellen, ist, warum hat Ganymede sowas nicht im Jupiter-System? Weil es nicht kalt genug ist, nehme ich mal an.
Also die Durchmischung letztlich...
Ganymede sind etwa genauso groß wie das Titan. 5200...
Titan ist von da, was seine Größe anbelangt, etwa anzusiedeln zwischen den beiden Jupiter-Monden, Callisto und Ganymede. Und hat eine vergleichbare Dichte und dementsprechend auch eine vergleichbare chemische Zusammensetzung. Aber aufgrund der... Dass es im Saturn noch kälter ist als am Jupiter-System, besteht halt an sich nur beim Titan die Möglichkeit, dass eben solche leichtflüchtigen Substanzen dann noch eingebaut werden konnten. Also beim Jupiter-System würden wir jetzt nicht unbedingt erwarten, dass wir da Methan flüssig bekommen.
Der Kurs ist noch ein bisschen größer als der Titan. Aber die stehen alle in derselben Liga.
Aber das spielt natürlich nicht nur die Größe, auch die Masse die Rolle. Wir können jetzt nicht nur über die Größe und die Körper vergleichen, sondern insbesondere, wenn wir für diesen Vergleich anstellen, dann können wir das machen für die Dichte und die Größe.
Das heißt, Titan wird da auch der Sonderling bleiben. Es ist nicht davon auszugehen, dass man jetzt bei den anderen Monden, dass sich da so etwas noch bildet. Theoretisch könnten sich ja dann noch weitere Zusammenballungen ergeben. Jetzt nicht unbedingt nächste Woche, aber über die nächsten Millionen Jahre. Oder ist dieses System so, wie es ist, jetzt weitgehend gefestigt und da wird sich nicht mehr viel abspielen?
Da ändert sich nichts mehr.
Obwohl das so eine wilde Waschstraße ist, wo sie sich gegenseitig befeuern.
Ja gut, aber das ist natürlich... Sie kriegen natürlich mit dieser Waschstraße nicht sehr viel Oberfläche weg. Das Material, das da wieder ins System reingeht und als Teilchen dort rumfliegt, das ist minimal. Aber an dem Grundzügen ändern sie nichts. Das ist seit 4,5 Milliarden Jahren da. Das ist im Anfang entstanden und hat sich gut stabilisiert und wird wahrscheinlich auch noch die nächsten 4,5 da bleiben. Erst wenn die Sonne sich anfängt...
Zu verändern...
.kräftig auszudehnen und zum Roten Riesen wird, dann wird das System hier noch mal grundlegende Erschütterungen kriegen. Aber wir wissen natürlich nicht, welche Überraschungen sonst noch vorliegen. Es gibt ein paar von diesen großen Körpern, von denen wir nicht die geringste Ahnung haben. Einer ist im Asteroidengürtel, heißt Ceres. Sozusagen fast ein Planet, zumindest inzwischen ein Kleinplanet. Da wird in 2015 die Sonde Dawn in den Orbit gehen. Das ist auch ein Eiskörper, der nochmal spannend wird, der sicherlich in diese Kategorie reingehört, obwohl er nicht ein Mond ist, aber eben ein großer Asteroid, der möglicherweise ähnliche Zusammensetzungen, ähnliche Verhältnisse hat und möglicherweise auch diesen Prozess eines Ozeans und Freisetzen von Material auf die Oberfläche. Und dann Charon ist ein großer Mond von Pluto, der auch wahrscheinlich für Überraschungen gut ist, wenn Pluto Express, heißt die glaube ich, die Sonde da draußen ankommt. Also es gibt noch einiges, was ungeklärt ist im Sonnensystem, aber grundsätzlich verändern sich die Dinge erst, wenn sie wieder einen ganz großen Prozess anstreuben. Und der ganz große Prozess oder der ganz große Treiber in dem System, in dem wir sind, ist die Sonne. Solang die stabil ist, passiert nicht viel, aber wenn die sich anfängt zu verändern, wird natürlich auch der Rest der Planeten sich wieder wahrscheinlich mit der Sonne aus dem System verabschieden.
Vorhin klang mehrfach an, so Cassini ist ja noch unterwegs und es wird permanent, werden neue Ziele gesucht und Cassini wird immer wieder auf neue Dinge hingesteuert und man nimmt hier mal Schwung und da mal Schwung. Wer ist denn da jetzt so die treibende Kraft? Also Cassini wird ja von NASA betrieben, aber es klang ja schon an, dieses Mal sind extrem viele Wissenschaftler angeschlossen, da gehört das DLR dann auch dazu. Das heißt, kommen dann auch von hier entsprechende Anfragen oder ist man da mit anderen Wissenschaftlern zusammen im Boot, um jetzt auch so bestimmte Fragen sich beantworten zu lassen?
Man ist mit anderen Wissenschaftlern im Boot. Man muss sich so eine Mission so vorstellen, dass im Grunde genommen ein Raumschiff ist sozusagen das Taxi für die Wissenschaftler und die Wissenschaftler sitzen jetzt nicht selber auf diesem Taxi, sondern sie sitzen mit Instrumenten da drauf. Und diese Instrumente messen wir. Da gibt es eine Kamera, gibt Spektrometer, Radar, was wir schon erzählt haben. Da gibt es Instrumente, die messen das Plasma, da gibt es ein Magnetfeld, da wird die Gravitation vermessen. Und jetzt ist es natürlich klar, es gibt natürlich eine Gruppe von Wissenschaftlern, die interessiert sich hauptsächlich für Titan, hauptsächlich für Eisenmond. Dann gibt es wieder welche, die interessieren sich für die Ringe oder für die Atmosphäre von Saturn. Und das wird ausgestritten. So kann man das eigentlich knapp und bündig sagen. Wer das beste wissenschaftliche Argument für seine Wissenschaft hat, der kriegt auch den Zuschlag für den nächsten nahen Vorbeiflug. Das heißt also, sie müssen ununterbrochen begründen, warum das, was sie tun als Wissenschaftler in dem Gebiet, was sie machen wollen, besser ist als das der anderen. Und da steht natürlich ganz klar Magnetosphäre, Saturnatmosphäre, Ringe, Titan, Eisenmonde, das steht natürlich im Widerstreit. Wir hätten vielleicht ein oder zwei Enceladus-Vorbeiflüge gekriegt, wenn wir nicht die Geissiere entdeckt hätten. Durch die Entdeckung der Geissiere war natürlich ein perfektes wissenschaftliches Argument vorhanden, das da gesagt hat, ja klar, dort passiert was. Und dann hat man versucht, zu viel nahe Vorbeiflüge und besonders durch diese Geissierwolke durch zu unternehmen, wie überhaupt im System machbar waren. Okay, das hat sozusagen andere wissenschaftliche Fragestellungen dann einfach getoppt. Und so ist es in dieser Community oder unter diesen Wissenschaftlern, da wird halt diskutiert und sicherlich gibt es hinterher dann einen, der Missionsprojektleiter, der dann die Entscheidung trifft und sagt, gut, das ist das wichtigste und das wird jetzt als nächstes gemacht, wenn es denn machbar ist. Aber das ist bei allen Missionen so.
Wie schnell muss man sich diesen Prozess jetzt vorstellen? Ich meine, Cassini spuckt ja Unmengen an Daten aus. Wir haben es eben schon gehört, da können auch Generationen sich im Prinzip von ernähren. Das heißt ja, wenn man dazu in der Lage ist und auch das richtige Glück hat, müsste man ja aus diesen Daten auch sehr schnell Erkenntnisse herausgewinnen können. Wie schnell muss man sich diesen Erkenntnisgewinn vorstellen? Also, wie sehr unterscheidet sich das Wissen über das Saturn-System, was man jetzt hat von vor fünf Jahren? Ist das so, dass man wirklich so wie jetzt hier in der Computerindustrie jedes Jahr schon wieder alles anders? Oder ist das eher ein gemächliches Voranschreiten? Solange man noch so eine aktive Sonde hat, müsste sich doch da eine Menge tun können.
Es tut sich, aber die Planung ist natürlich, die ist nicht so, dass wir uns heute überlegen, was wir morgen mit der Sonde beobachten. Sondern jede Veränderung, das heißt jedes Einschalten von einem Triebwerk an dieser Sonde wird natürlich erst am Boden getestet. Also wenn wir jetzt sagen, wir wollen näher an Enceladus vorbeifliegen, dann ist das ein Prozess, der ein halbes Jahr Planung hat. Also wir begründen, warum wir das wollen, dann wird geschaut, was man tun kann, dann wird der ganze Prozess simuliert, dann wird im Grunde genommen auf so eine Art theoretischen Computertest geguckt, was das Raumschiff tut, wenn man ihm das und das und das sagt und erst wenn das alles perfekt gelaufen ist, wird das Kommando auch an das Raumschiff gegeben. Das ist ein Prozess, der ungefähr ein halbes Jahr dauert. Dann machen sie das, dann kriegen sie ihre Daten zurück und dann geht es dann relativ schnell. Ich habe vorher erzählt von dem Beispiel, wo wir gesagt haben, okay, die Idee war, wenn es dort flüssige Seen und Meere auf Titanen gibt, dann müssten die in der Spiegelreflektion erscheinen. Dann machen sie einen Vorschlag und sagen, okay, wir wollen dann beobachten, wenn das Raumschiff so steht, dass es genau den gleichen Beobachtungswinkel hat, wie die Sonne auf die Oberfläche scheint. Dann wird geguckt, wann das passiert und war ein gutes Argument. Wir haben diese Beobachtung bekommen, wir haben es gemacht. Die Daten kamen zurück und zack, wir haben auch das Aufleuchten der Sonne in dem See gesehen. Das geht dann relativ schnell.
Der gesamte Prozess hat aber dann schon ein halbes Jahr.
Ja, ist ein halbes Jahr. Dann kriegen sie aber dann kriegen sie die Daten zurück. Die kommen ja auch nicht sofort runter, sondern es geht ein bisschen langsamer. Die müssen dann zuerst mal empfangen werden, dann müssen sie aufbereitet werden. Also ist nicht so, wenn sie die Beobachtung machen, dass sie dann sofort die Daten kriegen, sondern es dauert ein paar Tage. Aber dann, wenn sie Daten haben, gucken sie drauf und dann haben sie es ziemlich schnell. Aber meistens natürlich das, was sie sehen, ist nicht auf den ersten Blick eindeutig. Das heißt also, da setzen sich die Teams dann wieder zusammen, dann wird diskutiert, ist es das, was wir sehen, können wir es beweisen und dann wird es in größerem Rahmen diskutiert und dann schreiben sie eine Veröffentlichung und wenn die dann draußen ist, das heißt also, wenn der Rest der Community akzeptiert hat, was sie als wissenschaftliche Ergebnisse haben, dann ist es da. Man kann fast sagen, von dem Zeitpunkt, wie sie die Planung gemacht haben, bis zu dem, wo das Ergebnis auf dem Tisch liegt in der Fachzeitschrift, vergeht fast ein Jahr.
Ja gut, aber das findet ja jetzt die ganze Zeit statt, parallel von verschiedenen Wissenschaftlergruppen. Darauf wollte ich jetzt eigentlich hinaus. Also in der Summe aller Experimente, die dort angestoßen und letztlich durchgeführt und dann auch ausgewertet werden, wie sehr ergänzt sich das Gesamtbild, also wie schnell ergänzt sich dieses Gesamtbild auf das System dadurch? Also kommt man hier morgens rein und schlägt die Saturn-Zeitung auf und hat wieder eine generelle neue Erkenntnis, die einen auf neue Sachen bringt? Oder ist das eher alles so einmal im Monat oder vielleicht auch nur einmal im Jahr und das meiste ist uninteressant? Nur mal so ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen.
Nicht unbedingt. Sie haben bestimmte Phasen. Sie gucken natürlich, wie viele Veröffentlichungen rauskommen und was da passiert, was die anderen Teams tun. Und das passiert schon so im, würde ich mal sagen, Wochenrhythmus. Und sie kriegen natürlich eine Ballung, wenn irgendwas Besonderes ist. Das heißt, wenn sie einen dichten Titan-Verbeiflug haben, dann kommt natürlich mehr, als wenn das raumschließlich irgendwo zwischen allen bewegt. Oder einen dichten Mond-Verbeiflug haben, dann können sie richtig nachvollziehen. Es gibt dann immer wieder so richtige Pakete. Das heißt, sie haben das vor einem Jahr geplant und ein Jahr später kommt dann auch das richtige Paket für die Geschichte raus. Das ist schon so. Und das sich natürlich die Erkenntnis ununterbrochen verändert. Und was Frank Sol gerade gesagt hat, mit dem, was ein ganz großes Rätsel ist, wo kommt das Methan in der Atmosphäre her? Das kann ja dort nicht sein, weil es viel zu schnell zerfällt. Also die erste Idee war, ja klar, da gibt es einen Vulkanismus. Wir waren völlig sicher, dass wenn wir da anfangen zu gucken, dann sehen wir dort richtig schöne Vulkane. Und wir sehen auch, dass was passiert und dass das rauskommt. Zack, wir haben bisher nichts gefunden. Vielleicht ein bisschen so eine Andeutung, aber...
Also Vulkanismus im Sinne von so wie auf der Erde Vulkanismus oder dieser Kryovulkanismus.
Dieser Kryovulkanismus. Aber dort müssten die Geise ihre Ununterbrochen rausplatzen, sonst wäre die ja nicht da. Also muss es einen anderen Prozess geben. Dann kommt dazu, dass das Ding ja noch nicht 100% differenziert ist. Das heißt, das hat sich noch nicht alles getrennt, sondern das ist ein völlig anderer Körper. Das sind natürlich alles Dinge, die ich vorher nicht gewusst habe. Sie kriegen es nur raus, weil sie sagen, das, was ich erwartet habe, ist nicht da. Das passiert nicht, der Vulkan ist nicht da. Aber trotzdem ist es Methan da. Und dann müssen sie natürlich gucken, brauche ich erstmal eine Erklärung dafür. Und die Erklärung, die sie dann finden, 10, 20 Stück, die müssen sie dann beweisen. Und dann nachher gehen und sagen, was macht das Ding so kompliziert? Und dann gehen sie her und nehmen immer mehr Daten zusammen, Gravitationsfeld und alles, was man an Messungen hat. Und dann wird da langsam eine Geschichte draußen. Man fängt an zu begreifen, wie dieses System Titan funktioniert. Oder funktionieren könnte.
Aber es ist schon so eines der aktiveren Objekte gerade im Sonnensystem, wo einfach der Erkenntnis zu gewinnen stärker ist als, sagen wir mal, jetzt bei, weiß nicht, was jetzt gerade nicht so sehr unter Beobachtung ist, aber so mehr Kur wird gerade geflogen. Da zehrt man jetzt immer noch von den Huygens und von den Cassini-Daten am laufenden Meter.
Wir kriegen ja ohne unterbrochen neue Cassini-Daten. Das ist ein Puzzle.
Aber ist Huygens auch schon so komplett ausgewertet?
Huygens ist schon ziemlich weit ausgewertet. Also da gab es noch ein großes Problem über bestimmte Kalibrationen. Aber das ist weitgehend geklärt. Also ich denke, Huygens hat man schon ausgewertet. Aber Huygens ist natürlich insofern wichtig. Huygens sitzt auf einem Stück Oberfläche. Und unser Blick bei Huygens heißt, wir kennen dieses Stück Oberfläche ganz genau, aber wir hatten noch nicht sehr oft die Gelegenheit, es von Cassini aus dem Orbit zu beobachten. Und das ist ein bisschen eine Problematik. Das heißt also, wir sind zwar ganz nahe dran, wir kennen aber nicht die Entfernung. Für andere Stellen wissen wir sehr gut, was aus der Entfernung passiert ist. Wir sind aber nicht nahe dran. Und deswegen wird bei Huygens mit jedem Überflug von Cassini über die Landestelle die Erkenntnis größer über den Gesamtkontext, in dem sich die Huygens-Probe befindet. Und es ist ja nicht trivial. Zum Beispiel heißt es im Klartext, das hat ja Wetter. Das heißt also, wir sehen nicht notwendigerweise, selbst wenn wir drüberfliegen, wunderbarerweise die Landestelle so, wie wir es gerne hätten, sondern dort könnte, es ist nicht eine Wolke dazwischen, aber es ist durchaus diffuse Bedingungen, wo wir nicht so messen können, wie wir gerne wollen. Also man braucht auch ein bisschen Glück und man muss es halt oft genug machen. Insofern spielen die Sachen schon noch zusammen, aber die Erkenntnisse, die Huygens gebracht hat aus den Messungen, die sind zwar noch nicht 100% ausgewertet, aber das ist schon zum größten Teil schon verstanden, so kann man das sagen.
Was natürlich auch den Titanen besonders interessant macht, ist, dass wir dort die Möglichkeit haben, eben dieses Zusammenspiel oder diese Wechselwirkung von Inneren und Oberfläche und Atmosphäre. Das ist hochgradig dynamisch. Die Jahreszeiten, dass das alles auch gesteuert wird von diesen lang andauernden Jahreszeiten, das macht das natürlich unheimlich spannend. Dass wir auch jetzt dank Voyager und Dank Cassini die Möglichkeit haben, fast schon einen kompletten Zyklus abzudecken, das ist schon einmalig. Das wird auch Titan weiterhin an vorderster Stelle in der Planetenforschung belassen.
Von allen Objekten, die man sieht.
Ich denke, Titan aufgrund dieser Aktivität, die wir auch bei Enceladus oder IOM schon genannt haben, ist eines einer von diesen aktiven Satelliten und dementsprechend auch immer wieder gut für Überraschungen.
Was kann man denn da so an Meta-Erkenntnissen draus gewinnen? Man lernt natürlich jetzt viel mehr über Titan selbst. Man weiß mehr darüber, man versteht mehr darüber, man baut sich so seine Theorien und vielleicht auch irgendwann Beweise dafür, dass es eben so und so funktioniert. Aber es ist ja eigentlich auch immer interessant, dann festzustellen, was für generelle Erkenntnisse jetzt für die Planetenphysik zum Beispiel dabei herauskommt. Also wir sind ja jetzt die Zahl der Unbekannten in dem Genre nicht so ganz klar. Aber ich denke mal, das eine oder andere, was bei uns in der Erde abgeht, ist auch noch nicht unbedingt immer klar. Kann man denn vor der Beobachtung eines solchen Fernsystems Rückschlüsse ziehen oder vielleicht auch ein Erkenntnisgewinn ziehen für das Verständnis von Vorgängen hier bei uns auf der Erde auch?
Ich denke, das ist eines sozusagen der Triebfedern der Planetenforschung. Dadurch, dass wir uns in verschiedenen Zusammenhängen und uns unterschiedliche Objekte näher ansehen, eine ganze Menge darüber erkennen können, über Prozesse, die hier auf der Erde eine Rolle spielen. Ralf Jaumann hatte es schon im Zusammenhang mit der Geologie auch schon erwähnt, dass letztlich die Geologie überall ähnlich funktioniert. Und Ähnliches sollte natürlich auch gelten für die frühe Entwicklung, an die man als Planetenphysiker besonders interessiert ist. An der Einblick in die Entstehungsgeschichte, in die Differenzationsgeschichte, wie sich das Innere sozusagen im Lauf der Zeit entwickelt hat. Auch dort versuchen wir halt, Gemeinsamkeiten und Unterschiede zu erkennen. Und das ist besonders gut möglich an Objekten, die eben so eine aktive, heute noch aktive Phase durchlaufen.
Und gibt es da auch schon irgendwelche Erkenntnisse? Kann man da jetzt auch mal mit einem Beispiel kommen? Oder ist das eher so ein langsamer Prozess, der jetzt noch gar nicht absehbar ist? Also hat einem jetzt sozusagen die konkrete Forschung am Titan auch schon den einen oder anderen Rückschluss ermöglicht? Oder ist das nur absehbar, dass es darauf hinausläuft?
Ja, es hat uns zumindest schon gezeigt, dass auch die chemische Zusammensetzung eine große Rolle dabei spielt, wie solche Prozesse, eben solche strukturellen Prozesse ablaufen, dass das eine große Rolle spielen kann. Und ich denke, wichtig ist halt immer, durch diesen Vergleich von unterschiedlichen Objekten zu versuchen, die Prozesse besser zu verstehen, die letztlich bei der Planetenentstehung und Entwicklung eine Rolle spielen. Aber Titan hat uns da schon, gerade was das Verständnis von den Eismonten betrifft, doch schon wesentlich weitergebracht, als es noch vor wenigen Jahren der Fall war.
Was sind denn jetzt so die größten Fragezeichen?
Ganz kurz noch, man kann jetzt ein bisschen spekulieren, aber es gibt ja auf der Erde durchaus auch Dinge, wo Methan eine wichtige Rolle spielt, genau an dem Teil der Erde, der vielleicht sogar noch weniger erforscht ist, als zum Beispiel der Mond oder andere Dinge, das ist die Tiefsee. Und in der Tiefsee haben wir ja diese Methan-Klartrate. Das heißt also Methan gefangen in einem Eiswassergitter. Das ist eine der durchaus ernstzunehmenden Rohstoffquellen.
Also jetzt am Pohl?
Nein, in der Tiefsee. Dort haben sie kalte Temperaturen und Riesendrucke. Das heißt also, sie haben einen Zustand, wo ihnen das Methan fest wird. Und es gibt ja Spekulationen drüber, dass diese Methan-Konzentration immer in Verbindung mit Wasser, nennt man Klartrate, oder mit Eis. Und dass die zum Beispiel verantwortlich sind, wenn so eine Methan-Wolke da riesig aufstarkt, bei Mudertreieck und all diese Dinge, die so passieren. Das ist die eine Geschichte, die andere. Aber die Untersuchung von Methan bei tiefen Temperaturen und bei anderen Druckverhältnissen ist natürlich etwas, was schon zusammenhängt. Weil Methan ja auf der Erde auch vorkommt. Das ist ein schönes Beispiel. Wir haben, zumindest die amerikanischen Kollegen, sehr viel reingesteckt in die Untersuchung von Kohlenwasserstoffen. Und zwar Spektraluntersuchungen nicht im Labor, sondern mit Fernerkundungsinstrumenten weit weg. Zur Klärung, wie kann ich diese unterschiedlichen Bestandteile detektieren? Eben Methan, Ethan, Benzol, Acetylen und alles, was es da gibt. Und genau das kam bei der Geschichte mit der Ölplattform, die im Golf von Mexiko.
Die BP-Kalastrophe.
Und da hat ein amerikanischer Kollege, der auch sehr viel Basisarbeit für die Sache geleistet hat, nämlich das Detektieren von Kohlenwasserstoffen mit Fernerkundungsinstrumenten, war natürlich sofort dabei und haben natürlich jetzt mit dem Flugzeug dieses Ding überflogen und haben auf jeden Fall mal rausgekriegt, welche Bestandteile mit welcher Konzentration im Wasser sind.
Deepwater Horizon war das.
Genau. Und das heißt im Klartext, dass solche Sachen natürlich nicht direkt als Erkenntnis, aber methodisch immer wieder mit der Erde zusammenhängen. Kohlenwasserstoffe hat man natürlich in dem Sinne, dass man sie mit einem Fernerkundungsinstrument, im Sinne von wirklicher Fernerkundung, ich bin Kilometer weit davon weg und kann trotzdem feststellen, was es ist. Das hat man natürlich auf der Erde nicht gemacht. Das macht man natürlich, weil man Titan erfaschen wollte. Wenn das nicht passiert wäre, hätten wir auf jeden Fall nicht die spektralen Datenbanken gehabt, um solche Dinge, und dann zack, plötzlich kann man es auf der Erde auch brauchen. Das ist Zufall, aber solche Dinge passieren.
Also es ist bei der Wissenschaft, man weiß immer vorher nicht so richtig, wo es danach dann zur Anwendung kommen wird.
Wenn man es vorher genau wüsste, bräuchte man ja, dann würde man genau das tun, was man haben will. Meistens weiß man es aber nicht. Mensch reagiert oder Mensch agiert nach Versuch und Irrtum. Nicht zielgerichtet, sonst wär vieles auf unsere Welt anders, wie es ist.
Aber was ist denn jetzt so erkennbar, der größte Forscherwunsch? Also was zeichnet sich denn ab? Woran knabbert denn jetzt die wissenschaftliche Forschergemeinde im Saturn-System? Was sind denn jetzt so die heißesten Fragestellungen, wenn jetzt Huygens weitgehend ausgewertet ist, man über dieses und jenes schon Erkenntnisse gesammelt hat? Was sind die großen Fragezeichen, die jetzt angegangen werden sollen?
Ein bisschen was haben wir schon erwähnt. Also ein großes Fragezeichen ist Enceladus nach wie vor. Warum Enceladus, warum die anderen nicht? Was macht diesen grundlegenden Unterschied? Ein anderes Fragezeichen ist nach wie vor die Diskussion der Ring. Wie kommt er zustande? Warum ist er da? Warum ist er so speziell ausgeprägt?
Warum hat er nicht so frei geräumt wie der Ring der Sonne?
Oder wie der von Jupiter, oder wie der von Uranus, oder wie der von Neptun. Was macht dieses spezielle Ringsystem aus? Die anderen haben auch, aber nicht diese ausgeprägte Form. Wie ist er entstanden? Warum ist er noch da? Warum ist er so stabil? Ist es ein Langzeitphänomen? Ist es ein Kurzzeitphänomen? Ist er ganz alt? Ist er ganz jung? Das sind alles beliebig viele Diskussionen. Ein ganz großes Problem, das wir bisher noch nicht so richtig angesprochen haben, ist dieses dunkle Zeug, das in dem Saturn-System rumfliegt. Wir haben dunkle Oberflächen auf Hyperion, natürlich auf Iapetus, natürlich auf Phöbe. Was ist das für ein Material? Inzwischen sehen wir dieses Materialspektral auch durchs ganze System bis rein zu den Ringen. Wie werden die Monde, alle zeigen das, unterschiedlicher Konzentration, wie werden die durch dieses Material kontaminiert? Wie kommt dieses Material überhaupt in das System rein? Sind da mal zwei dunkle Körper kollidiert und seither driften die Überbleibsel dadurch?
Ist man das durch diese Spektralanalyse nicht aufgeschlüsselt normalerweise?
Nee, nicht so richtig.
Dann machen wir gleich, was da rumläuft.
Ja, aber...
Da ist einfach nur was Dunkel und man weiß nicht warum.
Da ist was Dunkel, was zum Beispiel auf Iapetus nur noch Reflektionseigenschaften von 1% oder in der Größenordnung von 1% richtig schwarz. Zack.
Das verschluckt das lichtförmlich.
Und zwar eine ganze Hemisphäre ist so. Okay, jetzt gibt es darüber eine ganze Reihe von Spekulationen. Es gibt auch spektrale Messungen, gibt es auch noch Diskussionen darüber. Früher hat man immer gedacht, das sind schon so organische Verbindungen. Man nennt es Toline. Das heißt also, wenn sie organisches Material unter Elektrozität und Magnetfeld setzen, dann können sie zumindest mal auf der Erde so ein schlapprig-dunkles, schleimiges Zeug erzeugen. Also Kunstname dafür ist Toline. Oder ist es doch was anderes? Das, was sich jetzt abzeichnet, ist, dass das Dunkle möglicherweise durch einen ganz feinen Anteil an Eisen kommt. Dass es nicht so anders ist als normale Wassereispartikel, die aber durch...
Mit Eisenspänen durchsetzten.
Ja, Nanofaseisen nennt man das also durch Versetzungen. Aber wo kommt das wieder her? Das ist eine große Frage. Es ist im ganzen Saturn-System verteilt, und zwar mit einer Konzentration von außen nach innen abnehmend. Das heißt auf Iapetus am stärksten. Der nächste ist Hyperion. Da ist es auch noch in großen Mengen vorhanden. Man findet es auf Titan. Wenn man weiter nach innen geht, man findet es auf allen Monden. Aber es wird auch auf den Ringen findet man es noch. Aber die Konzentration nimmt ab. Das heißt also, was ist das Rätsel von diesem dunklen Material? Früher hat man bei Iapetus gedacht, möglicherweise kommt es von innen und hat einen vulkanischen Ursprung. Aber das glaubt man nicht mehr, sondern es sieht schon so aus, als wäre das ganze System von außen kontaminiert worden. Ist da irgendwann mal in der äußeren Peripherie von Saturn eine große Katastrophe passiert? Sind zwei große dunkle Massen zusammengestoßen und dieses Zeug diffundiert jetzt immer noch durch das System? Oder ist es ein Prozess, der im ganzen Sonnensystem vorhanden ist, aber sich ausgerechnet bei Saturn konzentriert? Denn wir finden ähnliche spektrale Signaturen auch bei Jupiter. Es ist also etwas, was sowieso in die dunkle Materie im Sonnensystem vorhanden ist. Das sind große Fragen.
Vielleicht ist das jetzt alles schon so alt, dass es langsam Patina kriegt. Ein kleiner Tarnmantel wird da übergeschmissen, die wollen sich nicht erkunden lassen. Also ein richtiges Rätsel quasi. Man hat da keine guten Antworten, nur Theorien und die gilt es jetzt entsprechend zu beweisen.
Man hat auf jeden Fall schon mal jetzt ein bisschen Information über die Zusammensetzung dieser Geschichte, aber nicht mal eine vernünftige Theorie, wo es herkommt. Was heißt das, was der Ursprung von diesem Material ist.
Bei Iapetus kommt auch noch hinzu, dass er so stark abgeplattet ist, als wäre die Figur eingefroren worden bei einer Rotationsdauer von 16 Stunden. Das ist auch ein ganz großes Rätsel. So weit draußen, in so einer großen Entfernung vom Saturn, wo der Umlauf mehrere über 70 Tage dauert, wie kommt es dann, dass sozusagen die Figur eher darauf hindeutet, dass das ein sehr rascher Rotator war in der Vergangenheit. Das ist auch ein gewisses Indiz möglicherweise dafür, dass sich da tatsächlich Prozesse eben abgespielt haben, die katastrophal einzustufen sind.
Er hat einen richtigen Wulst um den Äquator rum. Das heißt also, dort ist ein richtiger, um den ganzen Äquator rum, eine Gebirgsgegend, die schon signifikant ist, ein paar Kilometer Höhe hat gegenüber dem Rest der Umgebung. Auch nicht ganz klar, wo das Ding wahrscheinlich mit dem Prozess der schnellen Rotation des Einfrühens beim Entstehen zusammenhängt. Aber das Ding ist einzigartig. Wir haben bisher keinen Körper im Sonnensystem gesehen, der so einen Wulst um den Äquator rum hat. Also was ist ihm da passiert? Also es gibt eine ganze Menge von Fragen.
Na höchstens bei den winzig kleinen Moonlets in den Ringen. Da gibt es auch einige, die auch wie ein UFO aussehen. In den Saturn-Ringen gibt es Dinge, die aussehen wie ein UFO? Nein, die zumindest ein sehr auffälligen Äquator-Wulst.
Zeigen.
Der ist noch auffälliger als beim Iapetus. Da ist die Vermutung, dass das durch Aggression von Ringpartikeln gekommen ist. Dieser zusätzliche Wulst.
Das heißt, dass auch noch diese Kleinstobjekte sich auch noch mal ihrer kleinen Privatringe zulegen und die dann einsammeln?
Klar, was wiederum heißen würde, dass die Physik auf allen Skalen funktioniert.
Der Herr der Ringe hätte da auf jeden Fall seine helle Freude. Ja, ich denke, jetzt sind wir hier ganz gut durchmarschiert durch das Saturn-System, was sich auf jeden Fall abzeichnet ist. Eine kleine Mission kann einen großen Unterschied machen. Auf einmal ist die Erkenntnisdichte extrem gewachsen. Und man versteht jetzt schon eine ganze Menge, aber es bleibt eben auch noch eine ganze Menge offen zu forschen. Also es ist auf jeden Fall kein Mangel an Aufgabenstellungen hier für das Planetenforschungsinstitut.
Auf keinen Fall. Und der Spannende dabei, muss ich ganz klar sagen, umso weiter sie rausgehen im Sonnensystem, aber ein Beispiel dafür, eine Jahreszeit dauert 30 Jahre da draußen. 30 Jahre sind eine Wissenschaftlerkarriere. Selbst wenn sie Zeit hätten, selbst wenn sie wirklich ein Raumschiff, 30 Jahre dort hätten, dann dauert sein ganzes Wissenschaftlerleben, bis sie einmal vom Sommer, vom Winter wieder zum Winter gekommen sind in dem System.
Da muss man sich mal die Bereiche so ein Systems aussuchen, wo gerade unmittelbar ein Umbruch stattfindet. Gut, ich denke an der Stelle können wir hier das Kapitel auch zumachen über das Saturn-System. Frank Sohl, Ralf Jaumann und das war's. Die 32. Ausgabe von Raumzeit. Wir schießen hier auch weiter durchs Sonnensystem. Ich denke, dass auch gerade ganz konkret die Betrachtung der einzelnen Bereiche unseres Sonnensystems hier noch mal stärker in den Fokus rücken wird in der nächsten Zeit. Aber das werden wir dann sehen, wenn es so weit ist. Bis dahin sage ich Tschüss und bis bald bei Raumzeit.